e
good morning um if you wouldn't mind
please rise and join me for the Pledge
of
Allegiance I pledge aliance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God
liy and jce for all all right take over
off good morning everybody I'm going to
open the public hearing for House Bill
62 and invite chairman Roy
to introduce his legislation good
morning thank you madam chairman and
members of the committee representative
Roy Rockingham
32 House Bill 62 was introduced by me at
the request of the Department of Defense
it is part of a program the Department
of Defense is carrying out Nationwide to
better um work with the states on
various issues related to military
members and family members this is one
of them where this has to do with um
protective orders where it is now
currently a protective order can be
issued by a military commander to any
service member however that protective
order is only good on base so once they
leave the military property the
protective order is no longer in effect
so what this bill does is it works it
into our system so it can be recognized
and used as evidence in the issuance of
a civilian protective order so that the
protection doesn't just stop at the
gates of the of the
base um as part of this program that the
military does they rank States on
friendliness to the military um how good
we treat the service members their
families and things of this nature and
you may wonder why that's important well
when it comes to if some of you may be
old enough to remember back the the base
closings during President Clinton's time
when it comes time to close bases they
look at which states are friendliest to
the service and service members the
Hampshire ranks number one or very close
to it as far as being a good place to
serve and families to live we want to
keep it that way and our part of a great
part of our economy is um based around
the military we have many military
contractors we have military bases some
some of them are very key and strategic
so I I want us to work hand in glove
with the military to continue to be good
neighbors and friends um I'll take
questions but there are experts on the
matter behind me who will be testifying
thank
you thank you representative um
representative Muse question question I
on the um on what actually happens to a
military protective order would the bill
that we're looking at would that
actually make that order enforcable
outside of the base or is there some
other mechanism in place um it's my
understanding what will happen is that
order will be used to get a civilian
order the military we can't
automatically just grant um that power
because the way the military Works um is
much different under the uniform Court
of military Justice you don't get to as
a soldier you don't get to say well I
want to oppose that order sir um that
doesn't go very far so thank you
leles thank you for taking my question
um being a Navy veteran there was always
uh Navy housing that surrounded
bases and I'm just wondering uh based
upon your testimony of uh protective
orders only being applicable on base uh
I would think that Navy housing if there
was to be domestic violence it would
occur in Navy housing could you tell me
uh what the current state of of uh the
law is and with this bill how that would
change it sure um and keep in mind
everything I say is subject to be
corrected by the people behind me um I
believe if the military owns that
housing then that order would then be in
effect if it's just rented by military
members I do not believe it would be so
what would happen is the the um
plaintiff would take her military order
or his military order go to our court
and show them that and then request a
civilian order that would then be good
outside the
thanks any further questions seeing none
thank you very much chairman Roy thank
you I apologize but I cannot read this
but
Nicole and it's not your fault I
couldn't read it I and fairness I have
thing okay so um if if you could go
ahead and give that to representative
sheer um what we would ask is if you
have written testimony you're passing
that around we'll most likely read that
while you're giving your testimony if
you could just kind of give us the
members of the
commit members of the committee for the
record my name is Nicole desay Bixler
I'm the deputy adant general for the
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services and I have here with me
today Lieutenant Colonel Jeffrey Chang
he's our state Judge Advocate thank you
and are you also a state representative
no okay I just is is that a state
representative tag are you I I'm a state
representative um well I'm a a state
employee is that what you
mean so it looks like a state
representative name tag is are you also
a state representative no do you see her
name I'm not I'm not a representative
I'm not a representative and I'm not a
member of the Senate or anything like
that yeah your name tag is exactly like
ours so I just wanted to I just wanted
to this is what they ordered for me Oh
no you're you're not in trouble at all I
just wanted to make sure I addressed you
correctly if you were a representative I
think it's same contract that purchased
yeah car carry on okay so I'm here today
to provide some um verbal testimony in
front of you you have my written
testimony and and basically I'm just
going to reiterate what representative
Roy has already mentioned which is
really this bill does two things number
one it
um it it basically allows for a military
protective order an Mo as we said say in
the military to um to be used as
evidence in a civilian proceeding should
a victim want to um get civilian
protective orders or uh restraining
order anything of that matter um on the
civilian side as representative Roy has
said the military protective order
really just
encompasses um activities within the
installation uh limits so it does not
carry out to um civilian communities so
uh so that's what it does and then
number two um the other thing that it
would do is the agitant general would be
able to reimburse travel funds for
victims who need to um travel to local
or civilian
proceedings so those two
things I'll take your questions
question is the military housing that
the military owns that is not on a base
itself sir we don't have any military
housing all of our national guard
members live within the civilian
you any other questions all
right representative Muse
could you walk us through the language
requesting and and the rationale for
them good morning um as as our uh Deputy
ad stated I'm I'm uh the state Judge
Advocate I'm also my full-time job is as
the New Hampshire National Guard general
Council um just for clarification um
yesterday we we had received um an
updated version from the Department of
Defense legislatively Aon which is what
um Miss uh Miss pix has handed out to
you all um and the changes are very
simple um and there really two changes
uh the first one is to uh for the
provision of the agin general to make
payments uh to reimburse for travel um
and the second one is that um a military
projective order will be admissible as
evidence in a proceeding there's no and
it's it's really been truncated down to
a page and a half and it's very very
straightforward right I don't see any
question any further questions thank you
very
much thank you ma'am
thank you madam chair ladies and
gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I am a
25-year Air Force veteran and I am a
27-year resident of the town of hookit
New Hampshire today I'm here
representing the state veterans advisory
committee and since this is a gr a group
that I don't see all that often and I
recognize some faces that I don't
recognize if you will um I want to tell
you just a little bit about what we do
uh we're chartered by state RSA 115
colon a
-8 you can also find us by going through
the dmabs website there's a a link to us
and and what we do and we're made up of
20 member organizations and these member
organizations are veteran service
organizations in our state that should
be familiar to you names like the
American Legion the Veterans of Foreign
Wars uh all of the all of the different
Services have a an advocacy agency I
personally represent the air and space
forces Association formerly the Air
Force Association but now that we've
added space we've added that to our name
as well um and I'm also our legislative
chairman and so what happens is when
when we come up with our thousand plus
uh lsrs that are going to come before
you folks I look through and I decide
which ones have veteran impact and then
we have a meeting as we did last night
and we discuss the language on them and
we decide whether we want to support
them or oppose them and then I come here
and I tell you what we've decided so we
do uh strongly support this bill uh
there's a list of 10 priorities from DOD
about military families this is this
runs right in there uh with uh that uh
that idea um and I will tell you just
personally um the highlight of my
professional life was when I became a FL
a squadron commander of a flying
Squadron and I always told my folks it's
not my job to do the mission it's my
it's your job to do the mission it's my
job to take care of you and your
families so I spend a lot of my time
working people problems and I think a
lot of good commanders sir Colonel
Bixler would tell you the same thing
that's what they view as their highest
priority and being in a military family
is stressful okay there's moves there's
deployments there's dealing with PTSD or
or medical issues that come back with
somebody who's potentially deployed and
protecting our families has got to be
right at the top of the list of what we
do it's sad when we have to issue a
military protective order but that
military protective order has got to
have some teeth with it you know it's
one thing to be in trouble on base it's
another thing to be able to take that
military protective order to a civilian
Court to help get a restraining order
for someone who lives off base as all of
our guard folks here in New Hampshire do
so we do support this legislation and
subject to your questions that's really
morning representative
lelis thank you for taking my question
uh I don't know whether my face is
familiar or not to you but your face is
familiar to me well that's good
sir um from one again I was a Navy
veteran submarine veteran and I can say
that it's hard for civilians to
understand what family separation does
to
relationships and when you're deployed
it doesn't matter what brand you're in
but when you're deployed and you come
back it's it's
extremely
stressful
irrespective of any particular
casualties that you've had in your in
your
deployment statistics show that young
service
people many times marriages do not
survive just from the stress of that
representative do you have a question
yes is it your testimony that we need to
take action when it comes to this sort
of thing I it's it's my testimony to you
that that I think that these incidents
of of especially where it gets to
domestic violence are relatively rare
but in those situations where that
happens our our highest duty is to
protect that that that military family
and if if that means issuing a military
protective order and using that
protective order to get a civilian
protective order because we don't have
our own base housing and things like
that where that that would carry a
little more weight than than we're in
you representative
Newman if a military member in the
National Guard in New Hampshire has one
of these protective orders against
someone who is either I don't know if it
makes a difference whether it's civilian
and Military
where would that order be in effect just
on what what kind of places like the
where where they have armories and stuff
like that any any property owned by
owned by the the the dod slth State
National Guard any property there that
would it would certainly apply while
they're there and in in another
circumstance and you have to understand
that that some of this is trying to get
common language in all the different
states and so like places that might
have housing uh on base where where
someone could live then the these things
would would carry more weight than they
do here in New Hampshire where um you
know that we don't have our our own
housing so it's hard it's hard for us
to control what happens when that person
leaves the base and goes home it will be
easier when this if this legislation
passes and this is used now my military
protective order that I would give say
as a commander would now be used in a
civilian uh civil court to get a
restraining order it would carry a
little bit more
weight thank
you if I just may ask a question for for
clarity would this would this work both
both directions so if the if the
perpetrator was in the military and the
victim was not and then or vice versa if
if the victim was in the military but
the perpetrator was not would that not I
guess if the victim was a was in the
military never mind I answered my
question as I asked it okay thank you
madam chair I see it
Newman do it work on
civilian if you
I I think that Times Like These the
reason that we have jge judge Advocates
General and lawyers are to answer this
kind of question
so welcome back welcome back see there's
a reason for lawyers right exactly we'll
debate that later no I'm just kidding
yeah I know I'm in support I'm in full
record um for for clarity uh military
protective orders can only be issued
against offenders or perpetrators that
are military okay
okay so the offender has to be in the
military the victim it's irrelevant if
they are if they're not that's corre
clarifying representative
gather um do you know if this what
you're asking for New Hampshire to do is
in any other
state I I I don't know uh it may be in
the the dod liaison written testimony
that was sent to the committee chair um
I I don't have that printed out
unfortunately I could look at it on my
phone but it would take years to to look
through and find it but um I just still
thought I just thought that maybe in
your research or something you might
have came across that maybe mass is
doing the same thing or New York or
somewhere so just ask I don't no problem
again you let me let me
um uh when when we're done here I will
email the the dod liaison officer and
ask her to provide the committee with
with that answer thank you thank you
thank you thank you they could they
could actually email the entire
committee that answer thank you very
much we also could we we have a
committee researcher that would be able
to help us if you guys weren't able to
to find it quickly okay all right Cena
rep representative Mur Murphy thank you
thank you for taking my question just um
two related questions if I could um I
wanted to know the financial assistance
that's uh referenced in the um in this
bill is it just for victims if the
victims are military or is that for any
victim if the perpetrator that is I
think that's intended for victims who
are not military I think it's intended
for family members but any Vic any
victim okay and may follow up follow
thank you um and the second question is
um who are those funds issued from and
you if somebody could answer that thank
you we have other people testifying I'm
sure that they will get them col Bixler
may may have an idea where that comes
from from a money
standpoint so the money would be paid
out of our state general funds for davs
for the Department of military Affairs
and veteran
services thank you okay thank you very
much I don't see any more questions
you're off the hook run okay thanks very
much Madam chair thanks for the assist
thank you very
Andre members I have a feeling we might
answered he was trained well thank you
um my name is Stephen Anders I'm an
assistant County attorney of marac
County I do support this legislation we
met a number of times you either this
summer or this fall and sort of went
over each section of it and hammered it
out and I think that at this point what
the amendment represents sort of the
best of what we came up with so I do
support it and I'm happy to answer
questions could you just Enlighten us
were there any questions that were asked
of the of the prior of the of the our
prior guests that maybe you could
clarify or no the only thing I would say
is that with reference to military
protective orders being admissible at
civil protective order hearings I don't
know that that actually changes anything
because under the current civil
protective order hearing rules The Rules
of Evidence don't apply so I think
there's certainly an argument that at
this point under the current rules you
could bring a military protective order
into one of those hearings um as
evidence this just clarifies that in
fact you can do that okay very good
thank you
rep representative
n thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question so it looks to me
like this is very specific in that it
can be used in evidence in um civilian
protective orders um which makes sense I
was wondering if you could speak a
little bit about um can this be used as
evidence in other um you know other
trials and other you know if it went
beyond that for
example is that already existing it
probably it probably wouldn't be able
I'm thinking in terms of like to get a
civilian protective order certainly it
could be used I think it could be used
to get for example a stalking order if
that were an issue because again The
Rules of Evidence don't necessarily
apply to obtaining a stalking order if
there was a violation of a civil
protective order in a criminal trial I
think the existence of a military
protective order would probably be um
excluded from that trial as essentially
outside of the Rules of Evidence okay
okay thank you
kyg good morning members of the
committee um as you know I'm Pamela kyg
I am the public policy specialist at the
New Hampshire Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual Violence um we're here um in
strong support of the amendment um that
I know uh rep Roy mentioned and other
speakers have mentioned this morning um
as was shared uh we worked with the New
England re uh region liaison of the US
Department of Defense State liaison
office U Melissa wette um in the fall
and summer uh to review the legislative
proposal um she wasn't able to be here
today but you've met um some of her
colleagues um and so uh we worked with a
lot of different state collaborators on
this I would like to just highlight
there's also a member of local law
enforcement who is prepared to answer uh
some of the questions as well um and we
just really appreciate um that um the
National Guard and representative Roy
brought this forward um just to
reiterate um it's a very straightforward
uh Amendment to the bill um it's really
important that victims have access to
critical financial assistance um often
they experience Financial burdens when
participating in legal proceedings Um
this can include loss of housing Health
Care Child Care financial support and
other Ben benefits um so this uh
provision will help offset those costs
by allowing victims who engage in the
court process to be reimbursed um for
related travel expenses so very
straightforward and then um secondly
with the military protective order
definition being added to RSA
173b again this is just very helpful um
to help bridge the gap really between
both the civilian and the military um
area when it comes to protecting victims
um everyone in the state who experiences
Domestic and Sexual Violence should have
protection and we just want to make sure
we um have the adequate tools and the
tool boxes to do that um but I
definitely would defer uh further
questions on the local jurisdiction
aspect of that to um Captain uh Clark in
the back um so uh please support the OTP
um on HB 62 and I'm yeah thank you all
much3
right I'm just going to go with the
Clark
Gard Gap hard is it Gap hard uh yes
good morning members of the House
criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee my name is Captain Clark Gart
and I work for the nationville police
department I'm also a Marine Corps
veteran thank you for this opportunity
to speak in support of House Bill 62 FN
specifically the proposed amendment to
paragraph 8 which seeks to make military
protective orders admissible as evidence
and not bound by the technical Rules of
Evidence in civilian Court proceedings
under New Hampshire's domestic violence
statute approval of this bill with
Amendment will act to increase the
ability of Civilian New Hampshire law
enforcement agencies to keep parties
protected by these orders safer from
abuse additionally this bill will help
bridge the gap between military and
civilian Justice systems providing a
more comprehensive and cohesive approach
to safeguarding those at risk as
described in the bill a military
protective order is an order issued to a
current member of the United States
armed forces the New Hampshire National
Guard or the National Guard of another
state or territory by the members Comm
commanding officer under the authority
of the uniform code of military Justice
they are issued at the discretion of the
commanding officer to maintain good
order and discipline and protect victims
from situations involving domestic
violence sexual assault stalking Dating
Violence and or child endangerment once
issued they restrain the member from
assaulting threatening abusing harassing
interfering with stalking or contacting
the protective
party despite the vast similarities
between the protective measures provided
by military protective orders and those
provided by CI civil domestic violence
and stocking protecting orders commonly
issued in the state violations of
military protective orders are
essentially unenforceable by New
Hampshire Law Enforcement Officers a
plausible scenario might involve a call
for service in which a civilian New
Hampshire police officer found a
defendant in a military protective order
to have been in contact with a protected
party who reported a domestic related
crime but there was insufficient
evidence to support a criminal complaint
a general practice of civilian police
officers is to avoid relying on evidence
during their investigations which they
believe might later be inadmissible in
court if this bill were to pass the
knowledge and confidence that military
protective orders are considered
admissible evidence would empower the
officers to use the contents of these
orders to support their investigations
potentially allowing them to
differentiate between an isolated
incident or a credible pattern of of
abuse unlike prosecutions of violations
of domestic violence or stocking
protective order cases in which the
issuing judge would not be called to
testify as a witness the non-judicial
nature of military protective orders
would likely require the issuing
commanding officer to appear in court
and testify in in an order they issued
if an order they issued was used to
support a criminal charge brought
forward by law enforcement this would be
equivalent to a civilian witness Who
provided the written or audio and video
recorded statement being subed to court
for their testimony while the best case
scenario would involve the commanding
officer being available to attend court
the demanding nature of military service
often requires a military members to
travel frequently as they are deployed
to various locations around the country
and the globe thus hindering their
availability it is critical that we
remove this existing barrier that can
limit the protections afforded to
victims in our state if this bill were
to pass and courts were not bound by
technical Rules of Evidence when
considering the admissibility of
military protective orders this would
mitigate prosecut prosecutorial concern
ins in the likelihood that the issuing
commanding officer was deployed and
unavailable for court by allowing these
orders to be admissible without the need
of supporting testimony from the issuing
commanding officer this would reduce the
occurrence of lengthy lengthy
continuances while also lessening the
chances of a victim having to testify on
their own behalf in conclusion the
proposed amendment to House Bill 62 will
allow the admissibility of military
protective orders in civilian courts
serving as a crucial step towards
ensuring the safety and protection of
victims I'm grateful for the opportunity
to speak on behalf of the important this
important legislation and to advocate
for the rights and protections of all
you thank you very much um do you happen
to have a copy of your testimony because
you said a lot of things that I actually
wanted to write down but I didn't want
to stop give you my copy well thank you
very much I'll take you up on that uh
representative are you okay to answer a
few questions Captain representative
Shar um I'm I'm a little confused now uh
uh attorney Enders said these military
protective orders would not be
admissible in proceedings where the
Rules of Evidence applied they'd only be
admissible at proceedings like a a a
victim seeking a protective order in
that where the Rules of Evidence don't
apply
so I may I may have misheard you but I
thought you said he suggested that we
don't want this will allow us to call
witnesses to to submit the
report in circumstances where otherwise
we'd have to wait to get the individual
there that would include criminal case
so let me simplify the question if I can
um is it your understanding that this uh
proposal would allow military protective
orders to be admissible at a criminal
trial I'm under that impression
hopefully I'm not
wrong uh yes okay I'm I'm under a
it anybody else
good representative GTH thank you m um
were you representing um the chief of
police or you representing
yourself I'm here as a member of the
Nashville Police Department Nashville
ma' just wanted to clar to you with that
welcome see no further questions thank
you very
much is there anybody else here wishing
to testify on House Bill 62 that is not
turned in a pink card seeing none I will
close the public hearing
will yes representative Murray would you
would you like to join the discussion I
was just going to say thank you madam
chair I was going to let everyone know
that the Department of Defense submitted
their testimony online and I emailed it
to the committee and from my research I
don't see any states having similar um
legislation
currently ladies and gentlemen that is
why she is the best clerk in the entire
house okay seeing nobody else I will
close the public hearing thank you all
yes sir
absolutely
good are you famili
um I am I am familiar
well is what veterans use to access Care
at
VA not because I don't get my my care to
VA
and
e
for
I hereby open the public hearing on
House Bill 87 and invite the prime
here going once going twice is anyone
else here signed up to speak on this
yeah would you mind just go ahead we'll
courtesy good morning chairman Roy
members of the committee I'm
representative saor D schaner from
Rockingham District 30 introducing HB 87
FN prohibiting posting of land not owned
by the poster Prime sponsor is
representative love he is absent today
so I read through this real quick
and basically don't post signs on
property that isn't yours and if you do
that that's a a
misdemeanor
that's would you say based on your
reading of that bill that it really is
meant so that people don't post no
hunting or trespassing on other people's
lands so as not to let Hunters go hunt
there
um I'm not a hunter myself I don't know
I mean I could conceive that somewhere
out there that behavior is probably
occurring but looking at this from a
private property rights perspective it
seems pretty cut and dry that folks who
don't if you don't own that land and
you're not authorized to post signs on
it you shouldn't be posting signs on
private property that's not
yours very good thank you um you don't
have to take any questions I just wanted
to see what you thought yeah that's fine
thanks anyone else want to testify in
this bill um seeing none I here by close
the public
11:15
e
I'm opening the public hearing on House
Bill 102 and I invite the prime sponsor
to introduce his
Bill thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee I'm happy to be
back with you today to introduce the
first of Two Bills of mine uh this bill
is substantially similar in concept to a
bill I brought last term however I very
much took the heart the various
criticisms that came from law
enforcement especially the sheriff's and
I removed all of what I believe were all
of the controversial
uh items that appeared in the bill to
really narrow down the scope of it to
just provide some measure of local
oversight for federal
actions
so it's quite simple sheriffs are the
top elected official for law enforcement
in their
County they have a
direct low ratio to the people who elect
them and represent them
that provides
accountability historically in America
sheriffs would oversee federal law
enforcement actions that were being
undertaken in their
counties this makes a lot of sense given
the way that our government as a whole
was designed the founders didn't want to
put all of the power in any one person
or Branch they divided us into three
branches Federal uh rather sorry
executive judicial and legislative they
divided the legislative into by Camal
two branches they created a federalist
structure where there's a dual Sovereign
between the state and the federal
government so everybody has a bit of a
check on everyone else and sheriffs were
envisioned from the very beginning as
having a check on other law enforcement
to include federal law enforcement which
at the time was very minimal when the
when the nation was founded there wasn't
much more than Marshals it was very
minimal federal law enforcement cuz
laws so we've entered an age once again
where I believe it's important that we
emphasize this traditional role of
sheriffs in
America we too often recently have seen
federal law
enforcement
ignore best practices in pursuit of
ideological goals and media headlines
that's how we wind up with situations
where tactical deadly force entry is
utilized on elderly disabled
people instead of the accepted best
practice of patterning their life to
decide where is the safest place to
interdict and take a person into custody
that minimizes the risk of deadly force
application it's how we wind up with
full Federal tactical teams pointing
loaded rifles at the children of pastors
for nonviolent misdemeanor
offenses we've now seen large numbers of
federal law enforcement placed on leave
or terminated under this new
Administration for malfeasant and for
political targeting of
dissidents while I very much hope we are
entering into a period of
reprieve we can't rest on our Laurels we
should provide a local elected law
enforcement Presence at federal police
actions in the state to observe and just
ensure that best practices are followed
respected and to answer a question
before it comes up because it was
brought to me a couple times does this
apply to ice because that's obviously a
big policy under the new Administration
as well my qu my answer to that would be
it would be discretionary cu the way
this bill is crafted is that it would
provide uh oversight for actions that
would be undertaken uh against New
Hampshire
residents and there is no legal um
mandate that a legal alien would be
considered a resident so it would be
discretionary uh at the sheriff's of
course discretion so with that I am
happy to take
questions thank you
um okay a couple things for me the The
Ice question it would seem to me that
you wouldn't be able to determine a
person's um status until an interdiction
actually happened so I don't know that
ice should be an exception um because
how do we know that that's not a citizen
or not until they propose some type of
action um second I'm confused by the the
maybe it's terminology maybe that's what
we need to look at yeah we call
oversight um if the sheriff if a sheriff
is accompanying for example um uh the
FBI on a on a an interdiction of some
type the sheriff can observe but he
really can't say hey you can't do that
hey you can't do this because they're
operating on a on a federal crime using
their Federal um rules and regulations
for their department or agency or
whatever whether we disagree with it or
not that would be something to be taken
up in court not between Law Enforcement
Officers out in the street so how do you
how do you feel about that that
terminology thank you and that's a
that's a very good question because it
kind of speaks to the heart of what's
going on and the specific language that
I use where it's a it's a may not a
shall so historically um there have been
quite a few situations in the history of
the United States where local sheriffs
did at least temporarily halt the um
actions being taken by federal law
enforcement based on the principle that
the Constitutional Sheriff is the
highest law enforcement officer in the
county and they have a check to be made
now that's one of those Concepts that
could go quite terrible depending on how
it's utilized so it really requires a
lot of discernment a lot of discretion
now I don't Envision many sheriffs
wanting to utilize that uh just
willy-nilly sort of but at the same time
I can Envision not under anything that's
even happened recently but I I could
Envision such a terrible circumstance
arising where
you have such out of control federal law
enforcement that are totally
disregarding rule of law and doing
things that are not right or just that
there may be a need to exercise that
kind of check not not from the court but
immediately on the spot to preserve life
and Limb and property of citizens of New
Hampshire so it's one of those areas
it's a bit of a gray area but there is a
lot of historical precedent and I don't
think is something that any of our
sheriffs are liable to
abuse um as a followup how how would our
sheriffs be aware of pending or active
Federal investigations or actions in our
state um and and how could we force them
to tell us if if we don't know thank you
and that's another very good question
this is one of those areas again where
it it's a matter of you can put in
statute that the sheriff should require
the federal government to notify them of
actions taken does the federal
government
comply May maybe maybe not but you only
have so much opportunity to check in
this kind of circumstance and checking
is going to be depend on the information
to receive now this is there's no
enforcement mechanism for that and
frankly I don't think there could be any
enforcement mechanism for that because
it's really more of a we're asking you
to play by these rules and if you don't
do it well there's not a whole lot we
can do about it but it's the way it
be finally for me
so you said there's historical precedent
and do you have historical cases that
that um any court cases at all that
where a sheriff was able to use any kind
of interdiction against the federal
government I don't care how old it is it
did it as it happened thank you I would
be happy to do a bit of research and see
if I can provide any court cases I don't
know that because what we're talking
about here is actually on the spot
immediate action being taken by law
enforcement without Court involvement so
whether there would be court cases
that specifically outline that I don't
know I'd be happy to provide cases where
the sheriffs did take measures to stop
something and I will look for any Court
presidents yeah definitely because as
far as I know right now the current
situation is federal takes precedent
over State and that's generally what
happens they come in if if there's two
crimes and it's for example um if
there's um a kidnapping it may be a
state charge and it's also a federal
charge the feds can exercise
jurisdiction just take it and that's the
way it is um but yeah if you have
research I'd be happy to hear it um
representative share uh the
best are you aware of the circumstance
during the Civil Rights era where the
federal government uh federal law
enforcement officers um uh came into
southern states to enforce federal law
sheriffs I am vaguely aware of the the
circumstances where in some cases
National Guard and FBI and Marshals
especially were utilized to do things
that were being opposed by States and
that's really a good example of the
check that I was talking about but in
the opposite direction because there's a
check going up to the federal level is
also a check from the federal level
going down to the state level especially
under the 14th Amendment to for equal
you representative n thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
so I uh I'm looking at kind of what the
what this would actually entail for
sheriffs because you know it says that
they would have a nonparticipating the
uh sheriff's deputies shall have a
non-participating presence in addition
to participatory so essentially what
this says to me is that they are
expected to be at any and all uh at
least in a nonparticipating capacity to
be at any and all uh Federal action in
our state um and so I'm wondering about
you know if you have any statistics um
around how often that happens not only
because that would be a heavy lift for
the sheriff's office but it would also
be a heavy lift on behalf of our
counties to to fund that extra
presence thank you for the question uh
yes there would be a increase in Need
for some Personnel in some cases I don't
think that would be a dramatic increase
first of all the rate at which these
Federal actions are happening is not the
same as the rate at which state level
actions are happening within the county
there's it's not happening as much uh
beyond that often times you're going to
find that local law enforcement
including sheriffs will already have a
presence at a lot of these things even
though it's usually a participatory
presence uh so what this would do would
be to perhaps reevaluate that concept
and say well do we want to have a
participatory presence and also a
non-participatory presence or just a
non-participatory presence there um
because I think it's important to have
that oversight somebody who's not
directly and actively involved in the
act action to exercise a uh sort of
objective and non tainted Judgment of
the circumstances can I follow up real
quick follow up I just wanted to because
one of the things that I was thinking
about in order to kind of Envision
exactly what kind of lift it would be
you know and in expense is do you have
any statistics around how many actions
say on a an annual basis happen in New
Hampshire corre thank you for the
question I don't have those statistics
in front of me I'd be happy to do a bit
of searching and see if I can find
something I don't know how the easy it's
going to be to break out the differences
between I I suspect the overwhelming
majority are going to be ice or cpb
related which would be discretionary
under this um so I don't know if it
breaks it out so I can look at just FBI
ATF other actions but I'll try okay
thank
you you um you might want to look a call
to the US attorney for the District of
New Hampshire any law enforcement action
would have to go through their office so
they theoretically whether they would
tell you the time of day or not I don't
know but theoretically they would
collect that information I would think
um and it I think it is that represent
n's question was is very key to the the
matter as far as expense goes you you
did say though it's discretionary uh so
if the sheriff says okay they're just um
doing a simple war and I looked at it
this guy's a
felon do they have to go on that thank
you yes so the the the discretionary
aspect was regarding actions that would
be taken against non-citizens so it
would not be discretionary as far as
actions taken against citizens or as you
later earlier rather uh mentioned
unknowns if we're exercising an unknown
action then that would apply to that as
well but if for instance there was a
detainer or something for an uh illegal
immigrant it would not necessarily apply
it would be discretionary in that case
does the bill say the sheriff or his
design or just the
sheriff it
it is suggesting that it could be the
sheriff or the sheriff's deputies so he
could so he could send he or she could
send deputies not not necessarily be
their and there's no amount so they
don't have to send 10 one is fine
correct all right thank you any further
questions uh representative
s thanks for taking my question are you
um aware of any other states that have
similar
legislation thank you for the question
I'm not aware of any other states that
have similar legislation such as this I
am aware of some other States including
Idaho and others that have
practices such as this in place where
they try to accompany um Federal actions
to
observe representative
Newman thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question um in uh line four you uh make
the following deletion the provision
visions of the Constitution of the
United States controlling in any and all
acts of Congress enacted in pursuance
thereof and I believe that this this
talks about
extradition and
says well could you just explain why
that was I believe we're going to the
next B replaced with I believe that's
the next bill we'll deal with it
noon okay see you no further questions
thank
you um the chair
Oran I'm concerned uh are we speaking to
hb12 that was one I put in the cardboard
okay cool thanks I was afraid maybe
you're doing the other on so these um I
don't have a whole lot um I don't want
to go into a whole lots of detail about
this but um the county this um the
county sheriffs have fairly limited
powers and I guess we are adding a power
to it and there's probably there's a
good idea behind it but I think this is
something to be more appropriately uh
that the Attorney General should be
doing of the state the um and they um I
believe they're already doing all this
uh things and the I think there's a
misunderstanding about the title Sheriff
so we call we have uh 10 subdivisions in
our state called counties and each
county has a sheriff I think they were
originally um also I think the court
clerk as well as a law enforcement
officer but you know the English civil
law you know what it says about sheriffs
U it doesn't necessarily apply to these
officials they basically just have the
name sheriff and certain duties and so
they don't have any the counties don't
have any um the counties are simply
subdivisions of the state that they did
for various purposes so I I feel uh
I feel this is a I think the county
sheriff's departments they do a great
job they have enough work to do but this
is beyond the scope of uh what they what
they should be doing and this is uh
something that should more appropriately
be these issues are extremely valid
represent bel's concerns are extremely
valid but this something that should be
addressed at the State issue not by the
sheriff's so that's why I feel this bill
is unnecessary and a bad idea and quite
possibly based on a misunderstanding of
what the word tariff means in New
Hampshire law versus what it may mean in
in um other contexts and other other
places so thanks I Ur you um I I'd Ur
you to either itl this bill or at least
uh amend it so it's the Attorney General
doing those things which would probably
a turn out to be unnecessary and B
require a total rewrite of the bill so
thanks thank you see no questions thank
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee uh my name is Joe H I live in
gilmington and uh I did put through the
portal a summary of what I uh can
summarize verbally now is that
that
bill is mostly for pre something to
happen rather than after the fact and I
I gave an example of the uh grey Lord
case out in Chicago where the FBI went
in to investigate crooked uh judges in
the
county and uh if he or they
FBI were to notify the uh Sheriff he
might have been in cahoots with the uh
Court Clerk or whatever so I think uh
this bill should be
rewarded maybe to uh deal with after the
fact the matters that you Mr chairman
noticed or said something about well
somebody is uh disagreeable with what
went on they can always go to court but
let me tell you a little story about
going to court on the Ed Brown case I
presume some of you know about that uh
2005-current
was the
uh us attorney you mentioned somebody
mentioned him
earlier uh went in to the clerk and said
we uh we're going to remand this case to
us we're going to you're going to
transfer it to us and the clerk obeyed
and uh I found out uh title 28 us code
636 C1 says yes on a civil case that can
be done but only at the consent of both
parties which never done so then it
escalated to a criminal matter and then
almost somebody you know uh Steven
mourier the US Marshall at the time
wrote a book on it it's probably for
sale over at the bookstore I invited him
here today I sent him an
email he didn't reply though but I did
contact his publisher and uh I I sent uh
various emails I gave you a b CDE E and
F you have printouts there in front of
you and he the publisher said stop
sending me all these emails I get enough
of them I said sure I mean that's fine
with me I mean I didn't tell him that
but that's I stopped and so uh there
are uh incidents in there that I won't
go into detail now but I mean if you
want to get the history of some of this
stuff I've been dealing with the federal
government ever since
1983 when red Beckman came to town
running for president and I used his
book on the case at the US District
Court uh and that's when Shane dine was
the chief judge there and I won the case
the IRS wanted money out of me on my
landlord tenants and red Beckman says oh
no that's an an investment that's not a
business so you know business tax is
different but I don't want to bore you
to death with all this other stuff I
just thought that uh just like in a a
previous bill that came to this
committee from representative Mike
rooster of
Pittsfield uh I had a problem with I was
helping out Ed Brown on his Homestead
RSA 480 colon 1-9 and 511 colon 2 tools
of your trade and I read about uh Nathan
Clifford he was born in Romney became a
US Supreme Court Judge he said the thing
to do is if somebody owes some money you
squeeze them down to half their Freehold
estate or Homestead and have them work
from there to pay off the debt and that
wasn't done in this case and the Brown
case I I tried to uh Ed Ed uh I knew Ed
before he went to court but I didn't
know the thing was happening until
halfway through you know an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure so
you know I just give up free legal
advice you know because I've been
through the School of Hard KNX and the
bottom line here is uh well let me back
up uh on that case his uh her I mean his
wife was a dentist and her dental office
equipment was sold down in nashille and
I I tried to attend that auction and I
was told by two US Treasury agents and
and two cops backed them up and said no
the owner doesn't want you here and I
said no no this is a public uh public
auction I'm a member of the public no
you're not
invited and so I sued uh the trucking
company in court because of that but the
secretary said oh no he he never said
that so it was the uh US Treasury agents
who lied they were in contempt of court
the judge ordered a uh public auction
and uh I try to get uh something done
but nothing the police commission down
there I went to them you know there's
check and balance in the
system and uh the the thing the system
doesn't work you know RSA 444 colon 3
and six you're supposed to post it and
file a report afterwards and then there
was not neither of them was done so
there statutes on the books that the
feds do not comply with they don't
comply with RSA 123 colon one that uh
says that they got a report to the
secretary of state with the uh plan and
description of their building over there
they never did that's in the record in
Florida they have to report to the
governor's office and in Missouri the
show me state they don't have to report
at all and there Larry becraft who put a
a website together he has all these
states and they're not doing it
and Bill Gardner I mean one of your
former State reps Dan ETA he put a bill
in to deal with that and Bill Gardner
one of the your committee members went
over to see him and his office and he uh
reversed it I mean it was going to be
voted yes but then they said no because
of some uh I don't
know interpretation I
guess I don't know what else to say I
just uh I think you about covered it but
um I I I do thank you for the
recommendation on the book um operation
greylord is that what you said oh that
well that's a report by the FBI Oh I
thought you said there was a book well
the book was written by uh Steven
mourier called uh Nobody Has To Die
thank you and I met Gary D Martino at an
event last fall in Belmont and uh he and
I had a picture taken together we're
friends now I mean back in the days when
I was arguing for Ed you know we like
almost took fists to each other you know
well not that not bad but you know me
mhm well anything I'm always looking for
I'm always looking for another good read
so I appreciate that yeah any questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony this
Enders good afternoon my name is Stephen
Anders I'm an assistant County attorney
at the marac county attorney's office um
I do see House Bill 102 as being
problematic for a a couple of reasons
the first part of it would
require the sheriff to have oversight
over all federal law enforcement actions
within the county I think that you'd be
surprised how many federal law
enforcement actions occur within Marat
County or within any County um obviously
within any County you've got the DEA the
ATF the marshals service FBI you also
have Homeland Security
investigations and I'm always surprised
to find out about new sort of federal
law enforcement agencies the one that
recently surprised me is um the state
department has a Diplomatic Security
office or agency which covers parts of
the State of New Hampshire and where
that comes up is people are using fake
passport cards now as identif ification
which implicates um the the state
department so they're operating as well
in in a number of counties and in terms
of
operating you may have one federal law
enforcement officer assisting local
police which is normally what what's
occurring with reference to a presence
at all federal uh warrants and federal
arrests while I don't know that you
could require the feds to notify us
ahead of time
those things generally warrants and
arrests
are excuse me are planned ahead of time
are
orchestrated um obviously law
enforcement operates in sort of a
military model where you have a command
structure and you would have an Incident
Commander for warrants and arrests and
what becomes difficult with this is it
brings in the sheriff not in the
planning stages but on scene to sort of
second Guess The Incident Commander and
make those calls so I do think that
there's some problematic language here
thank you attorney Enders it it seems to
me though it's clear what the sponsor's
intent is um is to get some type of a
handle on all I think you made the point
clear by just saying there's so many
agencies it's almost difficult to
conceive them um yeah I mean you didn't
mention the IRS the Secret Service I
mean it goes on and on so the clearly
that would be a heavy heavy lift to put
on one agency to track all those other
agencies but is there a way that you in
your mind that could reach the same goal
whereby the citizens of New Hampshire
would feel that their rights were at
least being um protected in some way by
overreach
my without a without getting political I
mean
without without being at political on
this
um there is obviously the Constitution
people are supposed to be obeying the
Constitution it's not one of these you
can obey the Constitution and if you
violate the constitution we're going to
suppress the evidence type thing it's a
hard and fast you're supposed to be
obeying the Constitution to the extent
you're not obeying the Constitution
you're violating people's constitutional
rights there are civil remedies
currently within the law um which allow
you to sue people and federal law
enforcement has my understanding is that
they have limited immunity so that if
they are in fact violating clearly
established constitutional rights they'd
be personally liable to that person for
those violations of those rights so I do
think that there's um there are systems
in place to prevent outof control law
enforcement
officers it seem 1983 for example I
believe would be the would provide for
treble damages whoever operating under
the color of law but the problem I I
think that perhaps the sponsor and and
others the citizen is again alone
against this Behemoth insure if he can
find an attorney willing to take it to
court and he can survive a motion to
dismiss at the lower levels of federal
court as it goes up um I wonder if it
wouldn't be inappropriate for it somehow
and I don't think this is necessarily
political because I'm pretty sure people
have both
political Persuasions feel at times the
federal government is is overstepped um
or or is about to overstep or so would
it not be inappropriate for some the
Attorney General at some level to to
represent the citizens of New Hampshire
to ensure that their rights weren't
government I don't is that too political
right I don't know if it would be the
Attorney General's position necessarily
as much as us attorney since the US
attorney would specifically oversee the
federal
government okay uh representative
share um would be fair to say that if
there's any federal official in New
Hampshire that has an awareness of a
good portion if not all of the federal
law enforcement activity going on on the
state it's probably the US attorney's
office yes do you know if the the State
Attorney General regularly talks with
the US attorney's
office do you have any
idea I don't know if the State Attorney
General's office regularly talks to the
US attorney's office I know that in
Marram County there is a
um I don't know the it's monthly or
bonly investigators meeting and it's not
uncommon at the investigators meeting
for representatives from the Attorney
General's office as well as the US
attorney's office as well as federal law
enforcement the sheriff's department
local law enforcement investigators we
all get together and talk on a regular
basis and uh you're aware are you aware
that there are a number of state federal
task force to address uh
address What would call state federal
issues absolutely in addition a lot of
um state law enforcement officers are
assigned to Federal task forces as we
call them tfos or Task Force officers so
for example the US Marshals office may
have five people there three of them may
be sworn US Marshals working for the US
Marshals office one may be a local
police officer who's a TFO assigned to
the the Marshall's office
thank
you represent
Newman thank you I hope I'm on the right
bill this
time the um on the fiscal note there is
a sentence under
methodology and it says since the County
government has no authority over Federal
actions and cannot compel federal
government to share information this
could lead to additional litigation at
the county level could you just kind of
comment some on what that means and what
kind of litigation it would be and where
it would come
from um I don't know if that would be
litigation uh initiated by the county to
try and get the federal government to
comply with the proposed
bill could it be the other way followup
could it be the other way around that
the county might might Sue and for that
that's what I mean it would be the
county suing the federal government in
order to get them to comply honestly I
don't think the federal government would
sue the county I think they would just
ignore the law thank
you um with regard to a question um the
other member asked um with regard to um
the fusion centers and things of that
nature do you know how many um us or in
your county how many um cross deputized
offices there are I I don't have that
exact number okay all right thank you um
see you no further questions thank you
if you're Tes thank you anyone else wish
to testify on this bill who has not
testified see none I here but I close
public
12:00
e
that I'm opening the public hearing on
House Bill 103 and I invite the prime
Spar to
spill good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee happy to be back with
you this bill admittedly probably the
most controversial one I'll have before
this committee this year is actually
more simple than it comes off if first
though the first the principle at play
with this bill is the principle of
Asylum Nations around the world
including the United States have
processes in place to receive and extend
Asylum protections for persons unjustly
persecuted by Foreign governments under
the principle of federalism which
according to our constitutions is the
nature of American governments the
States retain this power under the 10th
Amendment and dual sovereignty
really it shouldn't even be
controversial that states do in fact
have this power as the governor of New
York exercised this exact power just a
couple days ago in refusing extradition
to the state of Louisiana for somebody
that the governor has claimed is
politically
persecuted this bill simply lines out a
process by which the state of New
Hampshire could go about doing that same
sort of
thing we have unfortunately entered into
an age of lawfare punishment by
process and the political targeting of
opposition our president president Trump
was subjected to exactly this Paradigm
as were many of his supporters for the
past
decade imagine if he was a New Hampshire
instead of Florida Citizen
imagine the state of New York or
California refusing to back down from
criminal
prosecutions that would have prevented
him perhaps from serving his role as to
duly elected president we almost had
this scenario come to fruition until
that last sentencing hearing was
dismissed with no punishment in place I
bring this up not to be partisan but I
bring this up because if it can happen
to a duly elected president it can
anyone no no citizen is safe from that
kind of
treatment we're now seeing such legal
actions brought across the country for
things such as speech crimes
misinformation and various other newp
speak political Concepts that do not and
should not exist under the American form
of Republican government and
constitutional rights but is nonetheless
happening this bill just creates that
lawful process a simple
process to declare a
person politically persecuted when
charges are brought from another state
in this
Union and to refuse the extradition of
that person on that
basis and with that I would be happy to
take
questions thank you um I'm going to
start with the the the biggest problem I
had with it last time and I I still
haven't seen to overcome is article six
how uh excuse me yeah art it's article
four um of the Constitution the full
faith and credit how do we get beyond
that where the Constitution says we are
bound to recognize the laws of other
states and there's an extradition
portion in that same part of the
Constitution says that we have to honor
these exed requests how can we get
around that that's a very good question
well let me just finish
because the main problem is we believe
that that other state is violating the
Constitution by per politically person
uting someone how can we in turn violate
the constitution in order to save them
it's it's kind of that circular issue
you're right actually you made a very
good point in that distinction the very
last thing you said which is how can we
violate the constitution to protect
somebody who is being persecuted in
violation of the Constitution and that
actually comes down to the first
principles of play here which admittedly
this is a complicated question that I
think is going to have to be sorted out
a bit a bit further in the courts but
the reality of the situation is the
fundamental principle of American
government is is that it exists for the
purpose of upholding the rights of
American citizens that is the
foundational principle of it the exact
manners of in which it does that which
are laid out in the rest of the
Constitution are a secondary principle
to that first principle of upholding the
rights of American citizens so I believe
where there is a contradiction where
there is a conflict between those two
items we have to a on the side of
citizens thank you um
representative
Sher um so the extradition process is is
uh in on a day-to-day basis uh governed
correct no the the Expedition process is
governed under New Hampshire law which
is let me give me one second is the uh
it which is in accord with the
interstate uh the interstate rendition
uh act it's a Reform Act uh that is in a
is in place around the country between
states I'm I'm a little confused are you
suggesting that New Hampshire
extradition is governed not by state but
federal law yes New Hampshire well both
New Hampshire uh uh uh extradition is in
accord with the uniform extradition act
which every state has agreed to it it
flows from the federal extradition
Clause um and um so are you aware of
that I'm aware of of federal law that
exists on this subject but as he just
said all the states have agreed to that
under the current Paradigm there's
nothing saying a state cannot as the
governor of New York just did resend in
that agreement in part or in whole
through its own state
law and it's followup follow-up I'm
sorry um and it and and do you and do
you understand that it's
currently the fact the case that the
governor of New Hampshire can refuse to
extradite somebody for whatever reason
she
chooses that's the current state of the
compact this would at least in part
bring state law up to that exact same
standard yes well it's already the case
that under under the uniform extradition
act that the governor has of the
extraditing state has the authority to
not extradite somebody for whatever
reason thank you I I think the the
confusion that we're getting at here is
what's controlling um federal law is not
controlling of state government state
law is controlling of state government
so if we were to bring state law in
conformity in that manner by prescribing
that process for the governor there
would be no conflict there with the
federal law from what I'm understanding
for the purposes of clarity for the
committee um representative Sher is it
your position that current federal law
says that any governor who's a party to
the agreement can refuse extradition for
any reason that's both federal law and
state law and in the state law and in
the state the uniform extradition act
which is the federal law well it's it's
a law agreed to by all the states it's a
compact if you will yeah okay so but the
current Statute in New Hampshire does
not specify that the governor can refuse
does
it I haven't read that but that's that's
my understanding that the governor has
always had that power okay all right
thank you um representative Newman wait
hold on a second representative
rhods thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um I'm looking at
the line nine can you just it might
already be a process that I'm that I'm
not aware of what would it look like or
how would this work where it says
affirmed by the majority vote of the
House of Representatives how how would
that how would that be
executed thank you for that question so
it prescribes two methods by which
somebody could be uh receive essentially
receive Asylum under under state law uh
one method would be the governor the
other method would be a majority vote of
the house and that would be a simple
motion in the house to move and a vote
take thank you for the
followup so H how How would how would
the House of Representatives become
aware like become aware of this would
somebody would have to obviously make a
motion but I'm confused on is that
person contacting say you and then
you're bringing the motion to the
floor thank you it it just like um the
the privilege that exists under our
current rules and Mason's rules any
member would would simply be able to
bring a motion to that effect and have
on I this just made me think of a
question
so if we were to enact this and if every
other state were to enact this obviously
it would lead to bedum so what is the
what is your goal at that because
somewhere there's a goal to get someone
somewhere to say okay something has to
change
thank you I I don't know that it would
it would lead to bedum because I as has
already been made very clear this is a
provision that exists in federal law
that can be refused and it's not very
often utilized this is really
forward-looking it's not looking at
anything that has is occurring right
this moment it's forward-looking based
on the current legal environment where
there is law fair being pursued outside
of the bounds of what we would consider
normal constitutional law especially for
things like speech crimes where we've
seen people persecuted for so-called
misinformation which is just things that
people disagree with on the internet
stuff like that thank you representative
Newman I don't have a question thank
you represent n thank you Mr chair and
thanks for taking my question um
so a couple of things as we're going
through um what you know line four and
five we're actually deleting um the fact
that this would be um subject to the
provisions of the Constitution of the
United States controlling and I think
this is kind of addressing something
that has already been addressed so the
Constitution uh constitutionally
protected activity would be uh what it's
based on but then it's not subject to
the pro provisions of the um this that
same Constitution so um given that and
then also that the governor can do this
already um but now what we're adding in
is a vote of the House of
Representatives is it your contention
that in that case it is making it uh
over making it more or less uh politic
Al motivated because I I think you know
even in the example you used I think a
lot of people would probably disagree on
you know whether or not that was right
so if it's not protected by the Baseline
of the Constitution and yet uh it would
be subject to the House of
Representatives which
sways thank you for the question
actually I think there's a couple
questions in there I'd like to break out
individually so first there's a question
of the deletion of the the that little
line in here about the provision of
Constitution and acts of Congress you
don't have to have anything referring to
the United States Constitution in New
Hampshire law for the United States
Constitution to be controlling it just
it just is so that wouldn't actually
have any direct effect it's really more
important that we look the acts of
Congress part because as we've um
already seen with a little bit of
controversy that has occurred between
state and federal law state law controls
for what is occurring in the state not
federal law so it creates a little bit
of a weird situation where presently the
language in statute is confusing because
it suggests that acts of Congress
enacted in pursuance thereof therefore
it gives the authority to Congress for
the state extradition but at the same
time it prescribes a duty underneath it
that really eliminates the possibility
of a governor declaring somebody in any
not for extradition so it's confusing as
it currently exists that would simply
clarify things so that we're showing
we're demonstrating that it's not going
to be federal law that controls state
law state law is going to control state
law and we're going to outline exactly
how it's going to work um beyond that
the the next question comes to the
whether or not it's political well
clearly yes there is a political element
here because we're looking at somebody
who may be politically persecuted uh in
one of the other
states however it's not an easy bar to
meet the threshold of a majority vote of
the house under most conditions so it's
not like it's not like any random person
is just going to be winding up being
receiv Asylum it's going to have to take
a real movement to secure that kind of a
vote actually it would be much easier
under most circumstances to convince the
governor to declare that which under
federal law as we've heard the governor
already has the authority to do and this
just makes it a little more clean in
terms
of where we're looking for our Authority
follow up real quick follow up so when
you're talking about taking out this
this part where it says the provisions
of the Constitution of the United States
controlling so you said that that is
that is understood right that's already
understood but you chose to take it out
anyway so I'm just wondering you know
I'm just wondering why you include you
could have said in any all acts uh in
any and all acts of the Constitution and
I mean the I'm sorry any and all acts of
Congress enacted in the pursuance
thereof which you know I think actually
falls under that because otherwise it
would be challenged by the Constitution
we would understand that but um if you
wanted to just take out that part why
didn't you just take out that part
instead of also taking out thank you for
the question and it was just a matter of
making it as clean and as simple and as
short as possible because the con you
don't you just never have to say
Constitution controls because under
under law Constitution always controls
the more important part was eliminating
the acts of Congress part because that
gives direct authority to the federal
Congress to control New Hampshire state
law and extradition which is confusing
when we also have elements of state law
controlling for extradition so it was
really just a matter of shortening it
gotta thank you you I I would Hazard to
say that you you could write a law that
says um we're we're not going to obey
the Constitution it would mean nothing
because nothing trumps the Constitution
um any other questions see none thank
good afternoon my name is Stephen andw
I'm an assistant County attorney in
Marram County uh I I do think this bill
is problematic as well as attorney Sher
said there is a state law which is the
uniform criminal extradition law it's
New Hampshire state law it's New
Hampshire RSA
612 it's a uniform criminal extradition
law in the that all the states have
something similar to RSA
612 individual states have amended the
language slightly so there's there's
certain you know little tweaks in it but
each state has some version of a
uniformed criminal extradition law the
way it normally works is if a person say
commits a crime in Virginia and flees to
New Hampshire and there's a warrant for
their arrest from Virginia and they come
to the attention of law enforcement in
New Hampshire they'd be arrested as
what's normally referred to as a
fugitive from
Justice uh when you're arrested as a
fugitive from Justice You're normally
held there is a provision for you to be
released on bail but there it the
statute does talking about holding the
person and they're generally held I
think it's for 30 days with the option
to renew it for another 60 although I'm
not 100% sure those time frames but I
think all in all it gives you 90 days to
hold the person during that 90 day time
frame where the person's held they can
choose to either wave extradition and
essentially agree to go back to the
demanding state or they can fight their
extradition if a person decides they
want to fight their extradition then the
governor of the demanding state which in
this case would be
Virginia um writes to the governor of
New Hampshire and essentially files a
requisition and says I am asking that
you return this person to the state of
Virginia the governor of New Hampshire
does have the opportunity under
6124 um to investigate the crime RSA
6124 says the governor May investigate
case when a demand shall be made upon
the governor of this state by the
executive authority of another state for
the surrender of a person charged with a
crime the governor may call upon the
attorney general or any Prosecuting
officer in this state to investigate or
assist an investigating the demand and
to report to him the situation and
circumstances of the person so demanded
and whether he ought to be
surrendered so that statute currently
exists in New Hampshire law if the
governor does decide that they want to
send the person back to the demanding
State the issue was referred to as a
Governor's warrant the governor's
warrant is then served on the person
who's generally incarcerated at that
point they're then brought in front of
the court they're told under RSA 61210
that they have a right to he hius Corpus
in um the superior court and that if
they are not picked up in a reasonable
amount of time by the demanding State
they can again petition a superior court
uh for review of their custody
status so that's sort of the way it it
normally
works what this statute does is allow
New Hampshire to become a sanctuary
state for people that are claiming that
they're being politically
prosecuted
um I Heard the gentleman indicate that
the governor of New York has recently
declined to extradite someone that case
is a little different because in that
case my understanding is that it's a
Doctor Who's in New York already who
prescribed medication to a person in
Louisiana and again from my brief
looking at what this is is this is case
where a New York doctor um prescribed an
abortion drug to a woman in
Louisiana so that doctor didn't
necessarily commit a crime in Louisiana
and then flee to New York that doctor
was in New York the whole time and his
actions committed a crime in Louisiana
which makes it a little different under
the uniform criminal extradition law
because this is dealing with people who
commit a crime in one state and then
flee to a second
state um this is the whole extradition
thing is based in the United States
Constitution Article 4 section 2 of the
US Constitution is the extradition
clause the US Supreme Court has
case excuse me it's Puerto Rico versus
banstead banstead is r a n s a d the
case can be found at 483 US
219 and it's a 1987 case again that's
483 US 219 1987 case if anyone's
interested and essentially the US
Supreme Court in that case said that uh
Governors don't have the discretion
to um ignore a demand that when a
governor receives a demand from another
governor
that it must be honored the US Supreme
Court says its mandatory language
furthers its intended purposes to enable
each state to bring offenders to trial
as swiftly as possible in the state
where the alleged offense was committed
and to preclude any state from becoming
a sanctuary for fugitives of Justice
from another state what happened in uh
Puerto Rico versus banstead
is an
individual I don't remember what state
it was I want to say it was in the
midwest somewhere was accused to have
committed I believe it was a murder in
Puerto Rico and they left Puerto Rico
went back to whatever state they were in
in the midwest Puerto Rico tried to
extradite the individual back to Puerto
Rico the state refused to surrender them
and Puerto Rico actually sued the state
in a in federal court and said you don't
you don't have the authority to not
surrender them and and again that was
upheld so I think that as this bill is
written um in in addition to my my own
opinion being that not really a great
idea to set ourselves up to be a
sanctuary state for criminals from other
states to come here um I think it would
be unconstitutional under the current US
Constitution thank you um given that
Supreme Court case doesn't it make all
the the language in in the uniform
agreement or uniform law moot I mean
you say the person can petition the
governor and they can also behaved into
court where they can also argue it's all
mood if they have to honor isn't it I
mean if the con if the scotus already
said youve got to honor these I I think
it is that original provision that I
read
6124 um was passed in 1937 and again
that was part of the original uniform um
criminal extradition law
before um Barnstead banstead was okay
was decided in
1987 there was case law I believe from
the
1860s that talked about um fugitive yeah
fugitive slaves and essentially whether
or not those laws could be enforced the
federal government initially said no we
can't do that yeah and in banstead they
changed their mind and said No in fact
we can enforce extraditions
okay also with regard to this um you
brought up the New York case so
according to Brad that's clearly
unconstitutional and illegal um or are
is there the suggestion that be I mean
isn't there something called a long arm
principle yeah the long arm is generally
a civil thing what the difference is
that there's a difference between if I
go to Vermont commit a crime in Vermont
and flee to New Hampshire or whether I
commit a crime in Vermont from my house
in New Hampshire and there's certain
ways I could do that whether it's say
for example identity theft or that type
of thing um if I've committed the crime
physically in Vermont I don't think the
governor has a choice about whether or
not to extradite me into Vermont but if
I've never left my house in New
Hampshire I think the governor does have
a choice of whether or not to extradite
me to Vermont if I've never been there
before or if my crime occurred in New
Hampshire so this argument would have to
take place clearly in US District Court
based on the Supreme Court case to the
extent there was a lawsuit to force the
extradition would be in federal court
okay representative
Sher as a part of the extradition
process uh uh there's the hearing that
the person being that the the other
state is demanding state is asking to be
extradited there's a hearing at which uh
uh
um some
entity often the local prosecutor has to
right so I have not encountered that um
I you can de you can essentially say no
I'm not the person they're looking
for um and we would have to make a
showing that in fact you are the person
they're looking for but that generally
is limited to identification not
necessarily the elements of the crime
doesn't there have to be a showing that
there's
a pending valid charge in the demanding
State yes um and follow up I'm sorry I
apologize um I if you just want to ask
isn't there a a string of basic things
that have to be proven before someone is
just handed over is that where we're
going
yeah yeah is that what you're asking uh
that's part of what I'm asking
yeah um and and I do have a follow on
the the combination of the Constitution
and the uniform criminal extradition act
um
empowers the executive Authority in the
demanding State and in the potential
sending state to take certain actions to
render the uh individual into
custody looking at the the the the bill
as written it seems to involve the uh
State Legislature in that process uh
that's the proposal uh as one
alternative
is there are there potential separation
of powers concerns about bringing the
legislature into that process given the
development of the extradition
clause I I do think that you would face
separation of power issues
um because prosecution is a purely
executive
function thank
you if you're aware does the
Constitution of New Hampshire provide
any method or mechan mechanism for the
clemency I I don't think it does
um and I I know that they generally look
at it in the opposite way that the
legislature can't find someone guilty um
but I don't know I think clemency is a
purely executive function as well within
the governor's office I think normally I
would agree but I something in the back
of my mind is saying because we used to
be the court General Court there may be
some old things kicking around that I I
need to look at it um thank you further
Newman yeah I just have a quick question
about 612 Co colon 4 in the last few
sentences s indicate that there is a
report um as to whether he ought to be
surrendered surrended or not I suppose
is is implied so that so that is what
gives the authority to the governor to
make a determination on whether they
will um actually apply uh reply to the
demand or E extradite the person is that
I think that is implied in
6124 although I think under current case
law that would be unconstitutional for
them to not agree to exate the person
follow would would would that be New
Hampshire state law New Hampshire state
law makes this unconstitution or federal
state law federal law would make um RSA
6124 I think
unconstitutional thank
you see no further questions thank you
anyone else anyone else wishing to
testify in this bill who hasn't done so
seeing none here by Clos the public
e
uh here I open the public hearing on
House Bill
bill thank you Mr chairman members of
the
committee this bill may look a little
similar to one you saw last term it is
uh you passed it and the house passed it
last term but when it uh got to the
other
body uh there were a lot of department
heads that thought that that would
prevent them from doing Bank audits or
surprise OSHA inspections and other
things that this wasn't intended to
apply to so in the uh resubmission of
this
we have specifically added uh on page
two line 11 section n nothing in this
section shall be construed to limit
restrict or impair the access of any
governmental or regulatory agency to
buildings businesses or other premises
as provided by law so if they already
have permission under the law to do
their inspections for OSHA or do a bank
audit or uh any other such thing this
doesn't apply to them we're really
trying to just protect somebody's
private property that's in a join
joining to their house
now for any of you who are new and
weren't on the committee last year uh
let me explain the Open Fields doctrine
that this is trying to fix 100 years ago
the Supreme Court made a ruling during
prohibition to give the government full
and unfettered access to people's
private property except for their actual
dwelling in the immediate curtilage so
that they could go in and start smashing
Stills and taking people's uh moonshine
operations um that has stood for 100
years so that even your
right next to your house is not
inviolate from authorities coming in
without a warrant and without your
permission to post cameras or to look
for evidence or do what have you without
your permission even if you've got it
fenced off and posted and what have you
um the reason is because we haven't been
able to get a court a case up in front
of the Supreme Court that has standing
to have it
overturned there were a lot of erroneous
Supreme Court cases uh ruled on that
have been overturned over the years and
this is one that's just constantly been
missed because nobody's brought a case
withstanding so states are one by one
closing the loophole locally uh and
basically giving people back the privacy
of their lands as long as they are
fenced or posted the government agency
should
have landowner permission or a warrant
before they enter that property and with
that I'll take any
questions thank you representative um so
with the new change I'm I'm a I'm just a
little concerned that we may have um
thrown out the baby with the bath water
so to speak if it says they can go
anywhere any agency can go anywhere as
Allowed by law if the current state of
the law would allow them to do it um
would that in other words have we just
not really done anything
then I will leave that distinction to
the
professional that knows about this a lot
better than I am I I do um the language
is intended to state only as provided by
our state law in our passages not to
refer to the current ruling of the
Supreme Court law and I'm not sure if
that if you're what you're asking is
actually delineated by that comment yeah
I I I don't think there's a distinction
I think once the Supreme Court rules it
is the law of the land but uh Prof uh
representative Sher if you don't mind
um a couple questions um
the current state of the law with from
the US Supreme Court is that you need a
warrant to go onto somebody's property
that is characterized as the curtilage
that is the property on which their
houses that they do Daily Business so
it's not the case that the the people
can go on the police can go on any of
your property um part one part two was
that a question question or I'm getting
so do you want this bill
to overturn the US Supreme
Court current
policy that uh the police can go on
let's call it the back 40 without a
warrant the intent is to keep them off
of the back 40 if the back is posted or
fenced without a warrant or landowner
permission and that would be and fair to
say that would contradict the current US
Supreme Court law correct but all it's
doing is telling our state officials
that our state policy is you must get a
a warrant or permission before you do it
so it's been passed already in this
manner in I don't know 13 states or so
again it's a number I don't have exactly
representative
Newman I'm just wondering if that law
which talks about fenced and otherwise
enclosed in H or in part to exclude
intrudes was that is that different from
what was in the bill last time no okay
thank
you thank you I have to get back to my
own
McHugh thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon members of the
committee nice to see nice to see you
today thanks for running on time my
committee is hours behind so this is
great that you guys are right on time um
I'm here today for House Bill 206 and I
know you've heard most of this before
and my colleague from Rockingham
District 2 explained it adequately I'll
just give a couple examples why I'm here
to support it I know we passed it last
year and it did make it through the
Senate uh maybe I can help with that
this year couple of my colleagues uh
senators inis and genin and uh will
hopefully help out as well uh let me
just Begin by saying that um we're not
here to put obstacles in front of our
law enforcement this is really about
protecting some of the cor Val first of
all I'm Senator Tim MCU I represent
marac uh marac Milford ammeron Wilton
which is Senate District 11 sorry for
not introducing myself but we're not
here to put obstacles in front of our
law enforcement we're here to protect
some of the core values that are
enshrined right in our constitution
since we passed that Constitutional
Amendment guaranteeing our right to
privacy if you don't happen to remember
um last year the very first bill the
governor signed was the digital Privacy
Act it was sent a bill 255 and I was one
of the co-sponsors and I know this isn't
about digital privacy but it is about
privacy it's about simply asking our law
enforcement to get a warrant if you want
to go on the back 40 and a lot of states
have done it it's not a radical idea not
a radical idea Montana for instance the
courts enforced requirement of obtaining
obtaining a warrant a warrant uh
Montana's Supreme Court I like to think
we're a little like a little like
Montana in terms of respecting freedom
and liberty and State versus bulock in
1995 that was quite a long time ago
Tennessee did it in 1997 State versus
prior um so we have a long history of
respecting property rights and I think
this bill goes a step uh in doing that
and hopefully the technical correction
that was made in this draft will make it
through both bodies and I hope I can
help uh do that I think it's pretty
straightforward and fair it provides
some clear guidance making any evidence
obtained in violation of these rules in
admissible in court it reinforces the
property owner's rights uh and
simultaneously it allows the necessary
exceptions in cases of consent uh or
exent circumstances it allows our Law
Enforcement Act officers to act
decisively if they have an emergent
threat to life or Public Safety these
are critical things I'm a paramedic
myself uh so we know you know if we can
look through the window or if we hear
signs of distress that we can make uh
make an entrance make an entry uh when
we need to do so um so importantly this
is not a blanket restriction on any
government or regulatory agency um and
it does uh distinguish um conservation
officers and Fishing Game Commission
officers while preserving their
Authority in protecting our wildlife and
natural resources uh under uh 206 so I'm
urging you guys to support uh the
members of the committee to support this
particular draft and I hope when it
makes to the other body that I can help
it all the way through the process so
thank you very much for your time uh I'm
by no means an expert I know there's
some experts behind us in law
enforcement so I'm happy to try and take
questions but I'll probably defer to
some of the experts behind us well thank
you very much for your time thank you
for coming to see us today and endorsing
the
good afternoon chair Roy and uh Vice
chair Rose thank you for the opportunity
to testify to you uh this important bill
today uh my name is alist Whitney I am a
legislative counsel at The Institute for
justice uh J is a nonprofit public
interest law firm that for more than 30
years has worked around the country in
both state houses and coure houses to
protect people's property rights and um
as part of our work we have worked to
close this Open Fields loophole that
that uh representative Spain and Senator
McHugh were just talking about I'm going
to be very clear what does this bill do
this bill is a private property
protection bill it is not an anti-law
enforcement bill is not an
anti-government bill this protects the
back 40 this protects the woods behind
your home the the the field in front of
your home from government intrusion
unless the government agent has a
warrant uh an exception to the warrant
like an ex um excuse me an exigent
circumstance if somebody needed help if
they saw somebody destroying evidence
that might be relev relevant to a crime
being committed um or criminal
prosecution they can enter the property
um or they can go of course and walk
onto the land and get the land owners's
consent uh to uh look around and
investigate on the property um why is
this bill
needed uh several other states around
the country have uh including U Vermont
and New York uh have already uh extended
this Open Fields loophole protection to
their citizens um we are not seeing j is
not seeing any sort of evidence from
those states that law enforcement
activities are significantly frustrated
or that government cannot execute its
important functions because of this uh
this change and this heighten protection
that is afforded uh this is about
protecting people's property rights and
um making sure that people are secure in
their property and have that
privacy um just briefly I want to be
very clear too what does this bill not
do it does not
prevent uh anybody from going any
government agent from going up to
somebody's house just like a somebody
selling Girl Scout cookies or a you know
salesman can go up to somebody's house
knock on the door and say hey I'm here I
want to take a look around can I get
your consent or make contact or do a
welfare check this does not prevent
absolutely not prevent any other state
agency from uh investigating uh you know
or regulating Banks or hospitals this
only applies to private land that is
posted on somebody's private property
does not apply to a a business premises
like a building or otherwise so with
that I would strongly uh encourage you
and respectfully ask you to uh support
this bill and I am here to answer any
questions that you may have thank you so
much thank you um I'd like to ask the
question I asked the um sponsor
this addition to kind of alleviate the
worries that some people had with regard
to government agents being able to do
their non-law enforcement related jobs
is there no concern from your agency
that this might be too
broad um the intention behind that
language was to make it clear that other
premises meaning not secured premises or
not private land um would not be subject
to the scope of this bill this bill
really only applies to Simply private
land that is posted um it does not apply
to Banks it does not apply to schools it
does not apply to hospitals um if uh
chair Roy you think that language is is
too broad I would venture a guess and
say that rep Blain would be uh open to
amending it to clarify it um in a way
that would be acceptable but um again
the purpose is just to make it clear
that this is very limited in scope
understood and further question
representative share
um let's assume the property is posted
and fenced in uh what about
flyovers
um would they need a warrant for a
flyover under this
bill like a helicopter flying over and
looking down uh with enhanced uh
binoculars looking down on the property
no let's assume they know the property
is
posted that is a good question I do not
believe it would I mean we're talking
about the entry into somebody's private
property on on land um I guess it sort
of begs the question though what the
purpose of the fly if it's just a
helicopter flying over or if somebody's
trying to uh do surveillance yeah it
would be surveillance I mean there's
plenty of cases out there where uh the
police uh suspect a person is growing
marijuana on the back 40 you know some
of these cases are a lot of them are
from California and and um and
they hi uh get a helicopter or a plane
and fly over the property and take
pictures with enhanced uh vision for
lack of a better way of putting it um so
it would be for surveillance again let's
assume they know the property is posted
how does this address that at all or
should this address
that not to give a frustrating lawyer
answer but it does sort of depend right
I mean if they're flying over with the
purpose of looking into somebody's home
or curage or that activity is included
in that fly over that would be subject
to wellestablished pre-existing
constitutional protections for
somebody's home if it's somebody's
private land um I I suppose it would be
hard not to push back on the
hypothetical to know whether it's posted
or not but I think uh this
would I would have to get back to you to
give you a more fome answer on that sir
and I appreciate that because these are
these are the hard cases um you know I
there's are you aware of the cases that
that that say that you know they can
look at somebody's curtilage for example
there's a case with there a greenhouse
that's got some broken windows in it and
they which is part of the curtilage and
they Overlook it and US Supreme Court
has said that's fine that's not a Fourth
Amendment violation you aware that case
yes sir that's right I mean if something
is in plain view then it is not as
that's an exception to the Fourth
Amendment Doctrine right but if it's
something that is a part of like a
surveillance
program um or using drones to fly over
somebody's property uh that would
implicate more constitutional concerns
as it relates to like a surveillance
drag net right so it it it does matter
the intention of the officers or the
people surveilling whether they're
government agents or just private
citizens I think we've establish this
bill doesn't cover drones um and I
believe there's a case that talks about
how many feet above your house is your
own property and not so um I think that
would have to be covered in a totally
different bill that's right but I would
be happy to answer those uh additional
questions that you may have sir yeah
further questions see a none thank you
for your testimony thank you very
good afternoon my name is Stephen erson
I'm an assistant County attorney in
marac County um I I am opposed to this
bill the the difficulty is we already
have a Constitution and the Constitution
already says if law enforcement is
entering a place where there's an
expectation of privacy they need a
warrant or an exception to the warrant
requirement So based on that I guess I
don't really see necessarily the purpose
for this and I I start to get a little
confused when we start talking about the
back 40 and and what that means so to me
the back 40 means I own 40 acres of
property that is not posted in any way
so in New Hampshire if I own the back 40
meaning I own a giant piece of property
that's not posted in any way members of
the public are free to enter my property
to hunt to cross country ski to ride
mountain bikes to do whatever type of
recreation they want to do unless I
specifically post my property to
say you can't enter you can't hunt that
type of
thing so I have a difficult concept with
the idea that the back 40 is open to
everyone in the state except law
enforcement and I this bill refers to
posted land it it well it refers to
secured premises but then it also refers
to private
land so line 12 defines secured premises
meaning land which is
posted and it says unless authorized by
law the government shall not enter to
secured premises well that's already the
state of the law is if you have an
expectation of privacy in your property
law enforcement can't enter it without a
warrant I believe the Open Fields
Doctrine specifically says regardless if
it's posted or not a warrant's not
required I to me it comes down to
whether or not there's an expectation of
privacy in that property if you build
defense around your property I think
you're going to find that the police
need a warrant to enter that property um
then it refers to further down just
private
land which I guess private land is
somehow different than a secured
premises I would assume private land is
land owned by anybody upon ENT and it
requires upon entering private land that
you notify the landowner but again in
New Hampshire you can enter private land
for recreation purposes for hunting
purposes without notifying any land
owners and then it says
that you have to show your search
warrant upon entering private land but
you wouldn't necessarily need a search
warrant to enter private land that's not
a secured
premises um and
then again all of these statutes have
these exclusionary rules within them uh
six and seven say any evidence obtained
pursuant is inadmissible meaning you
would exclude all that evidence and
section seven talks about arrests
made would be
invalid um again we have a
constitutional theory of excluding
evidence for constitutional violations
and it always strikes me as
um as hard for me to accept that we have
the
same the same remedy for a statutory
violation as we would for a
constitutional violation meaning that
the government um loses all of their
evidence and then with reference to the
arrest being um invalid I don't know
that that necessarily makes sense
because an arrest is merely a way to get
a person into
court I believe it would be the fruit of
the poisonous tree by what you found on
during the arrest incident the arrest
but you could certainly just issue a
second arrest warrant or arrest them at
a different
time so I don't see um suppressing the
arrest as
being M making any sense to me but I'm
certainly happy to answer questions as
well did you did you oppose this last
um taking the Open Fields
Doctrine as it stands in assuming for
the sake of discussion that the the
citizens of New Hampshire have expressed
through their support of the recent
Constitutional Amendment for their their
will for privacy against the government
what would be an appropriate way to
express that to keep law enforcement
from disregarding the person's wishes
for privacy in light of the Open Fields
Doctrine how how in other words if it's
fencing that's an awful expensive thing
to make somebody have to do to keep
their private their property
private so whether or not you have a
reasonable expectation of privacy in a
place is is sort of a twofold inquiry
the first is whether or not you've
expressed a reasonable expectation of
privacy in that area and the second is
whether or not that's a expectation
that's Society is willing to
accept so I think certainly if you
posted your land in a way that showed
you had a reasonable expectation of
privacy within that land and that was
something that Society had was willing
to accept you you reach the point of the
government we need a warrant to enter
that
location further questions
representative Sher um I finally found
the case I was looking for are you aware
of Oliver versus United States where the
police entered posted and fenced
property and the Court held that the uh
the property owner did not have a
reasonable expectation of privacy which
is it's the kind of uh the current Open
Fields Doctrine case it's a 1984 case um
I can't say I'm familiar with it thank
you yeah that that's the actual the case
the Open Fields Doctrine case
representative
Newman I just have a question about one
of the things that you mentioned and it
had to do with the
fence and it talk it says um which is
fenced or otherwise enclosed and H or
apart so as to exclude
Intruders um I'm wondering whether that
means that if they put a fence up to
keep some cattle in out on their back 40
somewhere um it how did is that fit is
that is that to exclude Intruders or is
it to keep the cattle inside or or is
that an issue for this bill also it just
fenced part of it right I think that's
it certainly an arguable point about
what the purpose of the fence
is thank
you thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony the chair calls representative
gon
oh
no thank you Mr chair honorable
committee uh something that the last
testimony mentioned kind of got my
attention this is with regard to
Uniformed government officials acting in
an official capacity like I own a small
parcel of land that is not marked no
trespassing and I understand reasonably
that I may go out back and see
you know somebody hiking somebody cross
country skiing a dirt bike prudent use
non-damaging of that of that land
because it's not posted what I do not
expect to go into my backyard and see is
uniformed government officials or law
enforcement officers in an official
capacity now if there is an off-duty
police officer hiking on my land or
cross country skiing I would never know
that and that wouldn't bother me anyway
but this protects the private property
owner from government coming onto the
property in an official capacity without
a warrant whether it's a prudent search
or not and collecting evidence
intentionally or accidentally without
without um activating the proper
protocols so at fundamental basis this
is a property rights and an individual
rights Bill and one of the things I try
to remind people when I testify is it is
the duty of this body to protect the
rights of the people and this is one of
those things thank
you we appreciate you reminding them us
our duty any questions
seeing none thank you for your
Sergeant thank you Mr chairman members
of the
committee uh my name is Eric Sergeant I
am the Serv as Department
transportations min administr for the
Bureau of rway for those of you who may
not know the main function of the rway
bureau is to acquire lands for proposed
Highway projects some of the early steps
in this process is to establish the
limits of the public right of way to
accomplish this department must conduct
field surveys which may require entering
into private lands abing the
highway I would like to make clear that
these surveys are not to investigate any
crime or the property owner themselves
they are simply to locate boundary
monuments such as Granite bounds iron
pins fences and stone walls which is
necessary to determine the limits of the
RightWay additional features such as C
stange uh cover driveways buildings that
may be impacted by the proposed
improvements are also located to be
accurately plotted on Highway plans I
should note that there is no need to
enter the buildings but only locate the
outside
perimeters the Department's current
practice is to notify the budding
Property Owners within the project
limits 10 days prior to the upcoming
survey work
contact information is also provided if
the butter has any
questions Authority for these surveys is
granted to the department under RSA 228
colon
33 the proposed language of this bill
makes exceptions for fishing game and
their authority to enter private lands
but no other agency Our concern is this
may be construed as no agency other than
fishing game may enter private lands
without a search warrant therefore we
respectfully ask the committee consider
language being added to include the
authority Grant to the Department of
Transportation under RSA
22833 I do have that language here which
we have shared with the sponsor who sees
no issues with it have you do you have
the latest version of the bill with um
section nine starting on line 11 that
says nothing in this section shall be
construed to limit restrict or impair
the access of any governmental or
regulatory agency to buildings
businesses or other premises as provided
by law that sounds like it's tailor
written for you yes I I I am aware of
that sir thank you and it was only be
again because fishing game themselves
were called out and so no but so you're
okay with that current language then yes
okay good all right I thought you were
asking for something else too well we
did have some proposed language to add
to add the exception to include dep
Department of Transportation as well I
wonder if we start naming departments
specifically instead of broadly we're
going to start getting a long list as
long as you feel like this covers you
and specifically since
22833 provides you access by law this
seems to cover your agency um so I think
we we'll be fine with that any further
questions see none thank you for what
now you have one yeah go ahead yes I'm
sorry represent Newman do you know of
any other agencies that had that do that
kind of surveying work that that you and
it would cover all of you I think that's
basically what I'm not aware of a
specific that does
Goldstein sir did did you join the
priesthood you still in the law
enforcement I know you retired but I
didn't know you went
caller there we go for the record my
name is David Goldstein I'm presently
the retired Chief recently retired Chief
from Franklin Police Department I've
been a police officer for 46 years I'm
presently employed part-time by the
Rockham County Sheriff's Office uh as a
part-time deputy and I coordinating them
mental health and wellness uh efforts uh
however I also chair the chief's
legislative committee and that's why I
appear before you here today in
opposition to this
bill you've heard uh some very eloquent
testimony especially from the county
attorney's office and I won't uh spend
some time over that but I do think that
it's important and I have to agree with
Socrates in that we learn best by asking
questions and getting answers to those
questions so I'm going to try to provide
a few examples that might help put some
of this in perspective first and
foremost and perhaps most importantly is
exactly what was said a little bit
earlier we have prohibitions we have
paradigms we have guidelines by which we
as law enforcement have to function I
can no more walk into your house without
a reason um whether it be under court
order or for exigent circumstances than
anything it just does not happen
especially here in New Hampshire so to
fear government at least uniformed
government
I think is going a little bit of far of
what this would intend to do uh we feel
that this is a very wide sweeping type
of Bill and perhaps it's even an answer
in search of a question uh again because
of the guidelines that we have to
function
under for 23 of my 46 years in law
enforcement I spent with the New
Hampshire State Police for approximately
15 of those years I spent with the
narcotics intelligence unit which is now
the narcotics int uh uh invest ation
unit and the major crime unit uh while
with the major crime unit I was strictly
crime scenes I have investigated over
100 homicides in the state been involved
in those
investigations um and attorney Shar and
I go way back to the early 90s with that
um that included having to to do these
to apply for search warrants
Etc but here are some of the questions
that we have to answer that we have to
look at uh the potential for this build
May restrict the ability to enter onto
post of property for the service of
civil process as a member now of the of
a sheriff's department I understand
something that as a member of Municipal
policing which was earlier in my career
and as a member of State policing we
were prohibited from doing civil process
it's up to the Sheriff's Office to take
care of that so if a deputy walks up
onto a front porch where there's a no
trespassing sign is he or she in
violation uh would that mean that the
deputy would then have to go back to the
office apply for a search warant in
order to deliver that civil process uh
this may seem a little bit far a field
but quite frankly we don't believe that
it
is the uh timely service of protection
orders uh this is something that we take
very seriously and these orders protect
victims of abuse and by forcing law
enforcement to go through these
additional steps are we then denying
people uh the opportunity to be
protected by the courts and by law
enforcement especially with a no
trespassing sign pursuing a fleeing
suspect does this prohibit me from doing
so or does this come under the excy
component of um not having to have a
warrant but again if we pursue this
individual onto a posted property under
this bill are we then in violation and
if that individual opts to throw away
some evidence as he or she is running
away from us what happens to that I
can't seize that evidence perhaps
without a warrant and that may be short
lived evidence the reason I brought up
investigating homicides is the fact that
the Attorney General office many many
years ago gave us permission in crime
scene to go to the dead body and seize
that evidence because what's known as
short lived evidence this is stuff that
we have to take into account if there's
something burning maybe we might want to
put out the fire if it's evidentiary in
nature we can think of many many
examples that go along with this and
finally the restriction on any
government uh agents entry into posted
property would would would restrict
other areas uh fire inspectors the um
the Fire Marshals office is law
enforcement they are sworn Law
Enforcement Officers they carry guns so
uh they come under this building
inspection DCF uh investigations along
with a host of other stuff we have an
excellent system of checks and balances
in this state I've been a product of
those I've involved myself with those
for over four decades I understand the
restrictions that we have as do many
many of my colleagues if not all of my
colleagues so what we would ask is to
please itl this bill I'm happy to answer
any questions that you might
have thank you Chief um I I think the
the sponsor's intent and and they're
free to correct me if I'm wrong is that
if if I post my property no
trespassing and the police want to come
on they should have to get a warrant if
they see the no trespassing sign and I
don't think that's unreasonable because
that expresses an uh a a um expectation
of privacy this is mine it's not open
for the public if it's open for the
public I agree that law enforcement
should be able to go and I think the
examples you gave with regard to a
fleeing suspect that that would clearly
fall under the excy um as would the
evidence um and at the very least you
could seize the entire property pending
a warrant but and the Fire Marshals
being law um law enforcement officers
that is an interesting one however I
don't know why they'd be out in the
woods behind my house um but I I'm
trying to get at is how could we do this
in what is the current policy then in
New Hampshire if you if there is a no
trespassing sign are officers required
by law to get a warrant or can they just
ignore that and go
on my expectation would be yes get a
warrant without any of the other
exceptions right we can certainly look
at past case law uh that addresses this
in a number sometimes yes sometimes no
certainly uh I agree with you but again
let's use the back 40 example is that
merely a fence to keep the cows in or is
that a fence to keep people out yeah I
don't know if there's no and if there's
not a no trespassing sign does that mean
then I have the authority to go over
that fence you I heard the uh question
about uh aircraft Etc yes when I was in
NIU I was trained by the DEA to look
from aircraft to try to spot in those
days marijuana grows um is that again I
would say that that's fair and open uh
fair and open that there is already if
I'm not uh incorrect there is already
some case law that addresses aerial uh
surveillance today in the AE day and age
of uh drones certainly we have certain
restrictions but again if I'm going to
prepare aearch warrant I'm going to send
a drone today over that residence or
that area in order to to protect the
individuals that are then going to
exercise that warrant if that makes
sense in the old days what we would do
is we drive up we'd go stealthy we'
sneak around we take pictures we bring
it back for the affidavit today we don't
need to worry about that we have the
mechanical ability to do that I drone so
I think that this is something that the
legislature and the executive branch are
going we can debate it all we want but
it will eventually come down to the
judicial uh leg of the three-legged
stool yeah I I I mean it's unfortunate
if it has to I think that we could
probably find Common Ground um with
regard to the drones again I think that
would have to be a totally separate
issue but I I I believe the the oldest
case I can remember is they said the the
court said you could what you could see
with your naked eye or with use of
binoculars was fine as long as it wasn't
into someone's home where they had an
expectation of privacy but they drew the
line at what you could hear you weren't
allowed to enhance your hearing so it's
complicated and difficult for the
average citizen to understand uh thermal
for example you can go up with a drone
and you be find somebody whereas you
wouldn't be able to see them just flying
in a helicopter so is that enhanced so
I'd prefer we just stick to no
trespassing again the plan View Doctrine
would would come into play as well yeah
certainly thank you further
questions see you none thank you for
your
testim um chair calls The Honorable
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
to the committee for taking my testimony
I am here representing the New Hampshire
Municipal Association which is a
nonpartisan nonprofit voluntary
membership organization um every
municipality voluntarily and City the
state of New Hampshire is a member um
I'm testifying we are neutral on House
Bill 206 but we do have some concerns
and reservations that we'd like to raise
to the committee um um the first is the
definition of quote you know government
agent which says on line seven and8 of
page um I believe it's page one of the
bill yeah page one is um says means any
local or state official except where
otherwise noted who is employed or
contracted by a government body in this
state and
um I'm we're concerned because that
would include Municipal officials and it
would be very open and um there already
are as many people before me have
mentioned you know there's requirements
that you have to knock on the door ask
permission to go on the property If you
deny permission you can't go any further
than the curtilage of the property um
this is very much a concern of the
assessors right and they are following
these rules to the best of their
abilities when they're trying to do
property assessments which they're
regularly doing across the state as
required by Statute um our concern is
that there is already a process for you
know those specific government agents
like an assessor maybe some other kind
of um Municipal um employee to get an
administrative warrant under RSA
595b and we think that
um that there might be confusion about
what process they would go and which
statutes they'd be following um so
that's that is our concern um maybe our
concern is inaccurate but that's what's
been flagged to us when we reviewed it
with our legal we kind of shared those
similar concerns I want to bring it
forward to the rest of the committee um
as you work on this bill moving forward
during the legislative session and I
will take any
questions thank you any questions
representative share um do you have the
bill in front of you I do could you read
uh Roman numeral nine um and and and
tell me whether you think the conduct of
Municipal officials as you've described
you want me to read it to you no I I got
it in front of me okay sorry I have it
in front of me you asked me to read it I
don't know if you want me to read it out
read it to read it to yourself and tell
me whether it it included in that is the
conduct of assessors and other Municipal
officials performing their functions be
it with administ gr Warren or
not um we did discuss that internally
and yes but there was um I feel as if
there was another section Bill though
mistaken we did discuss that so nothing
in the section shall be construed to
limit restrict or impair access of any
governmental or regulatory agency to
buildings businesses or other premises
as provided by law but again our Our
concern is that there already is
existing statute and there already is
existing case law and other statutes
that restrict
you know those Municipal agents and when
they are restricted by the private
property owner there's a process for how
they go get a warrant and so we kind of
find this in some ways duplicative and
we wouldn't want our assessors to be
concerned that somehow they're violating
the law for doing their job and by and
by abiding by other statutes so it's
less of a you know I see your technical
point but it's more of a when we are
legislating um you know some of these
issues and it seems like it's already
pretty well established case law our
local officials um because not all of
them are experts in criminal justice
matters they do get concerned about how
they're able to do their
jobs I would assume that after we change
the law the municipal Association could
inform them all how to do their jobs I
think that if there's already a statute
in place that covers assessors they
would follow that statute there's
nothing in here that would say otherwise
in fact I think nine kind of directs
them to do that but of more concern is
there's um so many other people besides
assessors that have to go onto people's
property for various reasons which is
why we have to write it a little broader
than than one would hope to cover just
the folks you're worried about so I'm
not sure that we would be able to
address both the the privacy concerns of
the residents and um the assessors
beyond what we did here unless you have
some language
suggestions was oh he did okay go ahead
first you can go um I mean ours so after
hearing so part of my testimony was
going to be that we thought this bill
was more directed towards law
enforcement but clearly after what the
um sponsor has cited that his intent was
not just to um limit the search powers
of um and to make it more explicit what
their powers are in statute for law
enforcement that it is intended for this
to be more broad so we actually thought
it might be a mistake the definition of
government agent and for that to be a
little bit more narrow but um it sounds
as if the committee likes the
expansive term or the expansive
definition for government agent which
again we're neutral on the bill um you
know we do kind of agree I we would have
to do a lot of Education um but we like
to avoid ambiguities where we have to
educate a lot of Municipal officials
across the 232 towns in the state of New
Hampshire um when we can avoid that it
it's a benefit to our legal department
so but
um we'll look at that language represent
sh you had a follow-up question I didn't
see okay uh representative
Newman do you have a reference for the
the bill that that you say covers this
already and they might be in conflict
with each other based upon this
definition so we would be able to
compare and match what need we need to
maybe not every aspect of what's been
touched upon today but I think the
overall process for how an
administrative warrant is procured um
that's covered under RSA
595b so you know if if an assessor feels
as if someone is being dishonest or
there's some kind of modification that
they can't confirm to their property
that they need to make a an accurate
assessment just throwing that out in as
an example because we're discussing
assessors they would go through that
process so um you know I know a lot of
people don't like when the assessors
show up to their property and want to
reassess and um so that's part of the
you know when when we have additional
statutes that assessors you know feel as
if constituents that they're serving
whether you know people in their
residence that they're in the towns
where the residents have to have their
property reevaluated um you know if
people start citing statutes that might
not be applicable to them um because not
every person in the state of New
Hampshire is going to have the same
understanding of the law um it does make
their jobs much more difficult
especially when they're statutorily
followup I would just make make a
comment about the committee doesn't make
well I'll make a comment to you the
committee doesn't make it I mean our
questions are not an indication
necessarily of how we feel about the
bill one way or the other thank you okay
no I yeah to your point I I hope
not sometimes we just don't know I we're
here also to learn too that's why I sat
through the hearing because I thought we
thought that this was supposed to be for
law enforcement and you know now we're
like oh it is for everyone so I'm not
necessarily sure that's correct either I
I didn't hear that um myself so we may
have heard different things um having
said that I think that's all the
questions so thank you very much and if
we need anything else we know how to get
a hold of you appreciate
good afternoon um thank you uh for
hearing my testimony uh chairman Roy in
the committee um as you know my name is
uh bill brigh I a major with the state
police um I currently oversee our
Investigative Services Bureau um I I
came here as well to learn uh more about
what the uh the testimony how this how
this bill was perceived um by the by the
committee and by the uh everybody
testifying the the sponsors of the bill
and so forth um I think we've heard uh
plenty of uh testimony so uh both
perspective of law enforcement
prosecution uh prosecutors um as well as
uh you know the reasons why this bill is
brought forward so I won't hash over uh
much of that and I only uh the reason
that I did decide to um testify today
was to just offer up a couple more
points to consider one that I think uh
we should at least consider is that it
was testified earlier that um there have
been no cases to challenge uh in the
state of New Hampshire um on this issue
um at least that's what I heard I don't
know that for a fact myself but that's
what I heard today um I think we need to
at least consider if the reason that
that is the case is because of the way
law enforcement does their job in this
state already as it um relates to the
Open Fields Doctrine um so it's the
standard practice of the New Hampshire
State Police especially but law
enforcement in general in the state of
New Hampshire that if property is posted
that's that's private property that in
order to enter that property to continue
an investigation unless there's exigent
circumstances or one of the other uh
exclusions to um you know to the
evidence rules uh we would still need to
either get permission from the landowner
or obtain a warrant to enter that
property so that is that's common
practice um aside from the US uh Supreme
Court case law that was
um referenced here today
um I don't I don't have knowledge of of
that case um or how that would currently
apply to New Hampshire law but I do know
that uh in New Hampshire law enforcement
currently would need to seek a warrant
or get permission from the landowner to
enter posted property now the issue of
the unposted property uh if a law
enforcement officer was furthering their
investigation and they they came across
evidence on unposted property it would
still be our practice before that Pro
before that evidence was seized to seek
permission from a landowner so we we
come across crimes all the time
especially U my experience with the the
major crime unit investigating homicides
if we had a scene um in a public area if
we could determine who a landowner was
for that uh location we still seek out
um either um uh we still seek their
permission to be there and if we can't
obtain that permission to be there um we
would seek a warrant for that even
though it was in a public place where we
had the legal right to be um that's
common practice of the way we do
business now um so I just wanted to
offer those things up uh one thing I did
notice in the
statute uh it's section 7 Roman numeral
7 about uh arrests um being invalid um I
would just like to offer up that I think
that that's that may be dangerous
because um somebody may be an arrest may
be made based on evidence outside of uh
just this evidence that could be
excluded based on uh you know the the
entering of posted property so if there
was other evidence uh that gave probable
cause for an officer to make an arrest
besides that evidence that was obtained
um I would hate to see somebody have an
arrest be made invalid even though there
was uh evidence properly obtained in a
case I see what you're saying so in
other words it should just say any
evidence seized pursuant to that arrest
should be invalid not necessarily the
actual arrest invalid because if there
was inevitable Discovery or something
else the person should still be charged
not get off free because the because
this says the whole evidence exactly
yeah okay
um what you said earlier about the state
police um requiring a warrant if it's if
it's um posted that's policy correct
that's it's not a regulation or law it's
just well that's that's the Constitution
and Rules of Evidence our uh we may have
policy that says the same thing that
covers the the same things that are in
the the Constitution but and the Rules
of Evidence um so yeah it is backed up
by policy most likely I can't I don't
have it off the top of my head but my my
fear would be that I would lose that
evidence if I didn't do it properly and
get the either seek permission or get a
warrant well that goes to what you said
earlier about if it's in a public place
you still get it that's a belt and
suspenders just so that later on you
don't lose your evidence in a
suppression hearing because of something
stupid that's correct but it's not
currently the state of the Constitution
um according to that case if I post my
property and the police go on it and
discover something and they didn't get a
warrant for us it's admissible because
they said Open Fields doctorine says if
you don't have an expectation of privacy
just because you put up a a no
trespassing sign which seems strange to
me but it's the current state of the law
um representative Sher you had a
question yes are you aware of a a case
called uh State versus Smith which is a
2012 case which uh cites with approval
uh Oliver of the United States and holds
under the part one Article 19 of the New
Hampshire Constitution that that the
Open Fields Doctrine is a valid Doctrine
I'm not aware of that case no thank you
so yeah if if you could look up that
case and give me your opinion based on
the state police interpretation of that
case later just because that's that's
key um because that's in the Hampshire
case okay it was testified earlier that
there weren't cases challenging this and
that's why I testified that way what was
the case law state versus Smith okay uh
the citation is 163 New Hampshire
represent
Newman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question do you have any um comments
about the secured premises definition
where it includes
fencing um meaning that even if it's not
posted somehow fencing mixes into the
mix and may require the same thing as
posted fencing might yeah I mean I don't
have any specific comments to make about
that but I but if in in my opinion if uh
property is fenced I would consider that
as curtilage of um of the of the
residents of that property owners um
which would in my opinion fall under uh
the rules of evidence that I would need
to either get permission or a search
warrant to enter that property
followup you mentioned uh some concern
about uh article 7 on page two do you
have any concern about the article above
it that that doesn't talk about arrest
but it talks about evidence well I I
mean I think that's the issue at hand
right I mean according to the way that
this bill is written I mean it seems
like the intent is that well if if
somebody violates this uh this law then
they'll then the evidence will be lost
for a criminal case so I mean I
understand why that is there I pointed
out uh number seven just because I would
hate to have as the chair pointed out
you know an arrest be made invalid when
there was proper evidence obtained to to
establish probable cause for that arrest
in addition to evidence that was
obtained in uh you know on posted
property that fell under this uh this
law thank
you see no further questions thank you
very much for adding to the conversation
thank you is there anyone else wish to
testify was not done so see no one I you
brought closes public
now hereby open the public hearing on
House Bill 321 invite the prime sponsor
good afternoon chairman Roy members of
the committee for the record my name is
Dan veu I represent Hillsboro 34 in
Amherst thank you for the opportunity to
present HB 321 a bill that provides
drivers with additional time to pay
fines for certain motor vehicle
violations without requiring a court
appearance or undue financial hardship
this is a practical fair and responsible
reform that recognizes the financial
difficulties that financial difficulties
should not push people further into a
cycle of debt and license suspensions
under current law individuals who plead
guilty or noo contendre to a driving
violation must pay their fine within 30
days or risk further penalties including
license suspension HB 321 allows these
individuals to request an extension of
up to 90 days from the DMV and if
necessary a second 90day extension with
proof of financial
hardship this bill does not eliminate
fines penal dismiss penalties or allow
drivers to avoid responsibility instead
it provides a reasonable payment window
to allow individuals to pay Their fines
without the immediate risk of losing
drive this bill prevents unnecessary
license
suspensions license suspensions should
be reserved for public safety violations
not for people struggling to pay fines
on time suspension suspending a person's
license for an ability to pay creates a
cycle of debt and hardship that makes it
harder for them to work earn income and
pay the
fine this bill supports financially
struggling residents without eliminating
penalties many New Hampshire res
residents live paycheck to paycheck a
30-day deadline may be manageable for
some but for others a longer payment
window can make the difference between
compliance and suspension this bill does
not excuse non-payment it only grants
this bill provides relief for those who
qualif who may qualify for reduced fines
but can't afford to take time off from
work New Hampshire law allows some
individuals to qualify for reduced fines
based on financial hardship but they
must appear in court to justify their
income many low-income individuals
cannot afford to take that time off from
work and go through the process
especially if they work hourly jobs
where lost time directly impacts their
pay taking time off may also be a
hardship for their
employer as a result some people choose
to ple Guilty by mail and pay the fine
the full fine even when they might
qualify for a reduction simply because
they can't afford to miss time from work
HP 321 gives the individuals a better
option by allowing them to pay over time
without taking time off from work uh
reduces unnecessary Court appearances
right now individuals struggling to pay
fines must may may have to appear in
court to request an extension which
increases case loads for judges and
clerks by allowing drivers to request an
extension directly from the DMV this
bill simplifies the process and reduces
the burden on the judici
system uh there's a small Financial
impact of $36,000 a onetime upgrade to
the to the system uh otherwise there's
no long-term
impact um in summary this bill prevents
people from losing there ability to work
to simply because they need extra time
to pay a fine it reduces unnecessary
core involvement and streamlines DMV
procedures it helps low income
individuals who qualify for reduced fins
but cannot afford to take down off from
work and it has no long-term cost to the
state and insurance fines are still
collected um thank you and I welcome any
questions thank you um I I I'd like to
spill thank you for bringing it to us um
if you if you don't
mind couple quick questions the first
90-day extension there's no discretion
for the DMV to say no to but the second
it says they have to provide proof is
that correct I believe that's correct
yeah do do you know what the definition
of proof is I mean it it
seems unless we have a standard it could
change based on whoever the official is
at the moment looking at it right um I
kind of left that open to the ru making
process but if we should put some guards
on that that might be prudent okay uh
yes representative rhs thank you Mr
chair I turned it off um thank you Mr
chairman I'm not sure if you heard but
the chairman and I were kind of looking
at this and coming up with the same
question
um so you know you have the
step with would you have you given any
thought to instead of the step just
being able to with the first request
maybe have have the proof at that first
request and I definitely think we should
probably say what the proof needs to be
so it doesn't change per person but just
extend it
out maybe like with a payment plan from
that first time out instead of having to
go step steps I'm just thinking of the
person that they kind of think that
they're good they're in the clear and
now the next thing you know oops have to
go back and ask you know again do you
think it maybe it would be easier to
just kind of go right to the right to
the full Monte the first time around
with the ex with the exception with the
proof go straight to 180 days yes um
something to consider up to
yes I I would consider that if if uh
okay yeah I I kind of like the the step
process but okay you know I something to
work to think about yeah I'd work with
you on that okay thank you further
questions representative share
um thank you for taking my question have
you had conversation with John morasco
the director of Motor Vehicles about
this I did uh IAL talked with him and
some of his staff over the summer um
they don't have a position on this but
some of them have expressed that um this
is a situation that does come up and
people you know 30 days is just a little
bit too short you give them a few more
days and and it's fine um otherwise they
have to plead not guilty and go to court
and request a reduced fee or a payment
plan uh this kind of takes that burden
off the courts and gets a little bit
more time and the DMB can handle it uh
in their normal processes thank to to me
it it the issue is what is the intent of
the law is it you get a fine and that
fine is to punish you for your behavior
but it can turn from punishment into
destroying your life if you if you lose
license and you lose your you can't pay
for your car now your car's gone you
it's just a Snowball Effect right all
from a fine so I I think any attempt we
can make uh we should take so thank you
further questions representative new
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question um I also really like this
Bill I'm wondering one of the things
that you mentioned is that if you have
to go to court so I feel like all these
questions are in line but just to kind
of drill down a little bit further is
that if you have to take a day off to go
to court then I mean that could be the
whole thing to pay the fine in some
cases um and so I'm just wondering I
know that a lot of this is to leave to
the DMV so that they can you know put it
together in a way that works for them
but would you object to having something
that specified that it was something
that could be done um remotely that the
process was something that could be
remote because I think you
know what I would think is that uh you
would end up needing to go someplace to
demonstrate the proof right which would
be kind of taken away from the intent of
about thank you for that I I agree that
um I was thinking about that myself um
should it be just a process where you
send in the envelope and check check a
box it says I request the 90 days and
that first 90 days is automatic or you
know would would the DMV Envision a
process where somebody has to take time
off from work and still go through the
same so maybe we should specify that the
first round is more administrative and
thanks never as easy as it seems see you
none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you you anyone else is
there anyone else wishing to testify in
this bill who has not done so seeing
hearing I hereby open the public hearing
on House Bill
330 and invite the prime sponsor in just
is there anyone here wishing to testify
on House Bill
[Music]
330 yeah we just didn't have a sponsor
um I see a sea of orange placard does
everyone here against this bill
or yeah okay um seeing no one's here to
introduce it I don't think it's
necessary to hear all the fours if there
I mean against if there's no four um
having that having said that I'm going
to uh I I don't want to I don't want to
have you all testify with without
hearing
somebody about why we need the bill in
the first
place and well to my chrin I I see my
name as a co-sponsor and I don't recall
ever discussing this bill with
anybody
um yeah I would support the chair uh
introducing the bill so we can
cross-examine the chair right I think um
I will introduce the bill but I will not
good afternoon members of the committee
representative Roy Rockingham 32 I'm
introducing House Bill 330 on behalf of
Representative ol who whatever reason
could not be here this
[Music]
afternoon based on my review of this
bill it's discussing the privacy of
driver's licenses
and the dissemination of information
retained their form um for scanning
although now that I I read it I do
recall discussions
regarding when people purchase
cigarettes and things of that nature
their license is often scanned and the
question
comes what happens to the information
that's captured from that scan where
does it go and why is that necessary
versus just looking at it and seeing the
dates
so I would suggest that we open that up
for discussion and hear from these fine
folks behind us are going to tell us why
it's a great
Weston yeah yeah the the clerk has asked
if um anybody is here to F if if you
wish to testify if you could fill out a
pink card now so that we're not um in a
last minute situation that would be
awesome thank you take my coffee are you
leaving
gone good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Mora Weston uh I am
here today on behalf of the New England
connectivity and Telecommunications
Association and we are here in
opposition to House Bill
330 um necta members in New Hampshire
include breez line Charter
Communications and
Comcast together necta members service
approximately 485,000 customers and
offer their services to more than
695,000
locations in 185
communities uh necta is absolutely
committed to protecting personal
information of customers and employees
but we are concerned about potential
unintended consequences of the
legislation before
you it appears to us that the languages
drafted would prohibit businesses from
collecting and even reviewing basic
identifying information which is really
necessary uh for public safety for
example this could restrict the common
practice of using a driver's license as
an employment credential for employees
who for example operate a motor vehicle
on behalf of their
employer employers or thirdparty vendors
uh can verify driver's license
information with
DMV um and in fact as the way this is
drafted it appears that using the
information itself would create a
compliance issue even if images were not
necessarily
retained also it's important for us to
note that employers uh often require and
retain proof of a valid license
especially in the case where for example
somebody who's operating a motor vehicle
might have had a suspension of their
license in in the
past we also believe that this raises
issues with preventing identity
theft couple of quick examples with
mobile phone accounts driver's licenses
or other government documents are used
to verify
identification If This Were to become
law businesses may need additional
information for identification which is
referred to as knowledge-based
authentication it adds cost time
aggravation for consumers and and
basically creates challenges for
businesses to determine who's a
fraudster versus a a legitimate uh
customer um driver's licenses are also
used to confirm identity in the case
where fraudsters covertly swap SIM cards
or port phone numbers without having the
actual device the FCC actually requires
secure methods of authenticating a
customer before redirecting a phone
number and and this bill would prevent
uh us from being able to do that uh
additionally a lot of the terminology is
simply vague and um we urge the
committee to recommend this bill and
expedient uh to legislate based on the
forgoing reasons and I'm happy to answer
questions to the extent that I can thank
you
thank you very much vague language is
usually concerning um representative
Sher again in the interest of full
transparency Miss Weston is a former
student don't hold that against
me I I think we're good on the
disclosures for from now on it
entertains me exactly so we're going to
move on from that not really the person
sitting there as much
so
um I I I appreciate the value of
driver's licenses as uh uh for
businesses uh in terms of their use for
identification purposes if this bill
were modified to limit the use of
driver's licenses for B by businesses
for identification purposes would that
cause uh you less
concern I I would um I I think I'd like
to say that I think that the bill needs
more work than that we have terms for
example scann is
undefined the uh use of the word
government documents is overly broad um
finding information kept on a license
other than a name um that's private is
awfully narrow for example a street
address is not necessarily private
information so I we believe that the
bill has significant issues and we'd be
happy to work with stakeholders if
there's a desire to work on it but um we
think that the issues are many um would
it be fair to say that the followup I'm
sorry would it would it be fair to say
that uh uh best you can tell the concern
that this bill tries to reflect
is uh private citizens showing their
driver's licenses and the information on
them being used for much broader
purposes than just identification
purposes that's the concern behind this
bill sure we understand the privacy
concerns and we work to ensure the
privacy of our customers and employees
we certainly understand that desire
you nobody
good afternoon Madam chair honorable
members of the criminal justice and
Public Safety Committee for the record
my name is Ryan hail I'm vice president
of government relations for the New
Hampshire Bankers Association uh the New
Hampshire Bankers Association represents
40 member banks that employ roughly
6,000 employees here in New Hampshire um
we appreciate the opportunity to come
before you today to express our
opposition on House Bill 330 which
proposes significant restriction s on
the use and handling of driver's license
information by private entities while we
understand the importance of privacy and
protect and the protection of personal
information this bill creates
significant uh conflicts with the
existing federal law and regulations and
imposes excessive penalties um would
severely disrupt routine banking
operations that are critical for serving
New Hampshire residents and would expose
Banks and their customers to increased
risks of fraud um I'll first start with
the conflicts uh with federal law the
proposed prohibition on scanning
retaining of or copying of driver's
license information directly conflicts
with Federal Regulation that requires
Banks to collect retain and retain
identification documents for compliance
purposes which are largely uh largely
addressed at combating fraud and money
laundering uh for example us Patriot Act
mandates financial institutions to
verify the identity of customers as as
part of anti-money laundering
requirements this includes collection
and retention of government issued
identifications such as driver's license
to confirm customer identity and prevent
fraudulent activity there's also the
bank uh Bank secrecy act requires
similar uh recordkeeping to detect uh
and prevent Financial crimes uh
preventing Banks from retaining copies
of driver's license would undermine
their ability to meet these Federal
obligations and could result in
penalties for non-compliance
these Federal requirements could put New
Hampshire banks in untenable position of
choosing between violating state law and
federal law further it's unclear to us
whether the passage of this bill would
result in National preemption meaning
this legislation likely would not apply
to nationally chartered Banks doing
business here in New Hampshire if this
is in fact the case it would result in
an unlevel playing field for our New
Hampshire Charter Banks and put them at
a unfair disadvantage when competing for
business uh it also poses some
operational challenges for uh our
members um prohibiting the retention of
scanning driver's license would severely
disrupt routine banking operations that
rely on these practices to protect
consumers and ensure the Integrity of
financial transactions some examples are
opening accounts uh banks are required
to retain identification records to
verify the identity of new customers um
fraud prevention as I mentioned earlier
retaining copies of identification
documents is a essential in
investigating fraud or unauthorized
transactions and then finally loan
processing driver's license information
is often retained as part of loan
documentation uh to ensure compliance
with identity verification and
underwriting requirements without the
ability to retain this information Banks
would face significant operational
challenges leading to delays increased
costs and potential risk to
customers um as far as the penalties
that are in the bill um the imposition
of fines starting at $100,000 along with
mandatory lifetime identity theft
protection for affected individuals is
excessive and we feel disproportion uh
disproportionate these penalties would
create significant legal and financial
risks for financial institutions even in
cases where compliance with Federal Law
requires retention of
identification documents I think in New
Hampshire we're very fortunate to have a
strong and healthy economy supported by
a robust and banking industry including
the creation of new Banks which is not
common in many other states the threat
of severe penalties and criminal
liability would discourage Banks from
operating in New Hampshire or offering
certain Services ultimately harming
consumers and businesses in the state if
P pass HP 330 would undoubtedly have a
chilling effect on our economy taking
away from the New Hampshire
Advantage um so in conclusion while
well- intended hb33 conflicts with
federal law imposes impa impractical
restrictions on routine banking
operations and creates excessive legal
and financial risks these issues would
not only harm financial institutions but
also hinder the ability to effectively
serve the residents in businesses of New
Hampshire and before I finish um I would
like to also point out that in Commerce
they are dealing with a similar bill um
House Bill 77 that deals with um the
sale of alcohol and tobacco products um
there there is an amendment um that
passed the committee last week that uh
that prevent that would um uh prevent
the storing and retention of information
held on licenses and simply allow for
scanning as an age
verification um um tool and I'd also
like to point out the legislature passed
a bill last year Senate Bill 255 that
establishes state level privacy statute
um that requires uh businesses in the
state to protect personal information so
I feel that this issue is being
addressed and has been addressed um so
in closing for these reasons New
Hampshire Banker strongly opposes House
Bill 330 and urges the committee to
reject the Bill thank you for your time
I'm happy to take questions thank you
thank you very much could you just um I
was trying to write down as quickly as I
could what was the Senate bill that
passed last year Senate bill Senate Bill
250 55 I believe it was retained from
the prior year and I believe it was the
first bill the governor signed last year
okay thank you very much welcome rep
representative
Sher uh you are not a former student of
mine I am
not um same question as I asked uh uh
Miss Weston
uh what if the bill were to include
language something akin to use for uh a
permitted uh for identification use for
identification purposes only and use as
required by federal law if those two
things were in the bill and limited it
accordingly uh would you have any
remaining problems with the
bill I I think with anything the you
know we always like to say the devil's
in the detail but I think you know given
what you've just laid out um we I think
it would we we could
um take a neutral position on that but
we would be happy to work with this with
the committee and any other stakeholder
to ensure that it doesn't conflict with
uh federal law and that uh for our Point
our banks could still do business
without the concern and the fear of
violating federal law when trying to
comply with federal law thank you you're
very welcome representative
Muse thanks for taking my question not
everybody in New Hampshire has a
driver's license so so what happens to
people who don't when they come to a
bank and they want to take out a loan or
they want to go through you know
initiate one of the processes that
you've talked about yeah thank you for
your question it's and it's a great
question you know banks have so it's
governmen issued ID however Banks um and
we are actually we've been working with
for an example um Department of Health
and Human Services um to work on banking
foster children that don't have an adult
in their life they can't sign um you
know they can't sign that contract to
open up that bank account um so if they
don't have a government issued ID they
um can use other forms of ID for example
library cards student or um uh school ID
um generally speaking they'd have to
bring multiple forms of ID to verify
they are who they say they are um so
there are ways and policies it it really
depends on the financial institution and
Al you know
and going back to working with um DHHS
and banking foster kids I know our
members have worked with their regulator
as well the FDIC um to confirm the
policies that they have in place are
requirements so it's fair to say that if
somebody doesn't have a driver's license
there are a lot of additional steps and
a lot of additional work that need to
happen on your end to verify their
identity I I I I would say that as a
correct statement thank
you right seeing no further questions
guy great thank you madam chair members
of the committee for the record my name
is Tom prol uh from Demmer prol and
Thomas I'm here today representing the
new Hampshire retail association and as
the other uh folks behind me have
indicated we are also opposed to this
legislation um the retailers of all
sizes use uh scanning and driver's
licenses as a way to protect age
restricted items such as alcohol and
tobacco and as Ryan had mentioned
previously we have worked with the house
Commerce Committee on amended language
to allow for the scanning of driver's
licenses in those specific age
restricted item uh situations however it
prevents the retaining and sharing of
that information however retailers do
use uh driver's licenses for a number of
other issues um you can go to Best Buy
and get a Best Buy credit card um I
think those instances would fall under
what uh Ryan mentioned with the bank
secrecy act um and also many of you have
been to a um a home improvement retailer
where they offer the ability to rent a
vehicle uh a truck or tools um and they
need to use driver's licenses to verify
uh the person's allowed to drive a
vehicle and uh they are who they say
they are um again also as Ryan mentioned
he really hit a lot of good points Ryan
um uh cill 255 also outlines a number of
privacy protections including um
requiring uh businesses of certain sizes
to have a mechanism for someone to reach
out and have whatever information that
was provided uh removed so we think
there's adequate protections already in
place based on the wisdom of uh this
legislature in previous years and uh we
don't think the bill is needed and uh we
would ask that you find it in expedient
to
legislate thank thank you very much
representative sheer uh same question
I've asked M Weston and Mr hail uh if
the bill were amended to include
language such as use for permitting use
for identification purposes on
and use as required by federal law would
that uh that eliminate most of your
objections to the bill you know I'm not
sure I'd have to see what what that
language looks like and how it
interplays with other sections of law um
and and what the uses would be for that
so I'd like to see it before I make a
decision um follow up followup um I
think particularly with retailers uh
might it be the case that those who uh
who are concerned about their privacy
are concerned that retailers are going
to use uh the information on the
driver's licenses for purposes other
than identification and those required
by federal law for example uh start
sending the mail
um you do you do you appreciate that
concern I I do appreciate that concern
and I think that's why we were fine with
the passage of Seno 255 which we felt
addressed adequately addressed uh
consumer concerns in that
area last followup follow up um and as I
read uh Senate Bill 255 it puts the onus
on the consumer to to uh take initiative
to protect uh the use of the information
uh Beyond its use for identity is that
right that's my understanding nothing
forther thank
you nothing
further old lawyer Instinct sorry didn't
realize you're on the stand there did
you Tom you know I'm happy to be here I
think you did just happy to be
here
busted I don't oh so close so
representative
Muse are you aware of any retailers who
use data that they gather from licenses
uh for anything other than
identification purposes you know I I'm
there's so many retailers out there that
use this for so many different areas I
uh would hesitate to offer a broad
statement or response to
you thank you very much you yes you are
free to go we certainly don't want to
stting to a to a to a challenge that's
for
by share rhs committee members for the
record I'm Rick Fabrizio senior director
of advocacy and public affairs for the
business and industry Association of New
Hampshire we are the Statewide Chamber
of Commerce uh I'll be brief and not uh
repeat a lot of what we've heard um Bia
does
uh this bill because it would bro
broadly restrict and
complicate um the collection of basic
information for routine industry
protocols in doing so if this bill were
to pass it would remove the individual's
right to Grant consent for the use of
their information for its stated
purpose uh it's important to point out
that these routine business Protocols
are in fact uh permitted under the New
Hampshire driver Privacy Act which is
RSA 260 col 14 it restricts the ability
to sell rent or transfer motor vehicle
records for any unauthorized use as Ryan
had mentioned it could also run a foul
of the federal drivers protect privacy
protection act which also allows
legitimate business needs in
transactions initiated by the individual
to verify accuracy of personal
information now Bia understands the per
the importance of safeguarding the
personal information of New Hampshire
residents we LED efforts to pass the New
Hampshire data Privacy Act which was SP
255 but is now RSA
507 um it's the state's first
comprehensive consumer data proection uh
Protection Law um and I would add that
the most troubling part uh for bi's
consideration is the fine structure for
this um at1 th000
$100,000 it dwarfs uh what is already in
RSA 260 colon 14 which allows $2,500 for
each violation of selling renting or
transferring the information with that
questions thank you very much
representative Sher same question that
I've asked before I want you could no my
my concern would be the existence of the
state and federal law which this would
conflict with even if you were to start
to allow for certain banking
transactions but you'd be ending up
having so many car votes that I don't
know what you'd have left for a law
there was a similar more Focus Bill uh
before Transportation last session and
different groups came in and said hey
could we get this for insurance can we
get this for banking how about for test
drives of cars and it just didn't
Advance because there were too many
things to
adjust if there was a way forward on
that I still think a major issue is the
what I see as access liability exposure
for uh businesses those the $100,000 is
a pretty staggering
you I don't see any further questions
thank you very much thank
you is this 330 is there anybody else
with us um that would like to testify
for house bow 3:30 that has not turned
in a pain card seeing none I will close
the public heing
and we are
3:45 nobody panic I know it's hard to
believe that I made a mistake I'm being
sarcastic as I make one every time I'm
here and I'm looking at times um I was
looking at house bow 338 to being the
one that we just did so um I will now
open the public hearing for House Bill
338 and and welcome the prime sponsor to
know thank you to the chairman and to
all committee
members if you just want to hold on one
second we have a lot of moving Parts
behind you we're not going to be able to
hear you which won't be very fair to you
so let's just give everybody one second
to settle down I didn't realize we were
going to have so many moving Parts after
I asked you to come up well apparently I
came into the table and I cleared the
room sorry about that you really did
look what's
happening onone on the bright side I
will be very brief because it's a very
straightforward bill for the record my
name is Daniel popovic Miller I
represent wiam Rockingham 17 and I'm the
prime sponsor of this bipartisan
Bill basically the bill does exactly one
thing it tries to align the standards
needed for various um law enforcement
branches to um stop and search people
and it does so by bringing the
conservation officers to the same
probable cause standard that every other
law enforcement agency that I'm aware of
is um subject to the intent is to just
make sure that everybody's rights are
protected equally regardless of which
law enforcement agency they happen to
encounter and it is um something that I
want worked with with boobin this um
Bill there was a similar
Bill the previous term that went much
further than this that required warrants
warrants to stop anybody and whatnot and
that obviously didn't get anywhere
because that was
unreasonable I do believe that this is a
very reasonable reasonable approach to
that problem and I'd be happy to answer
any questions from the committee thank
you
I'm sorry if if I missed it but what
exactly does this bill what does the
bill do I don't unless I missed that it
changes the uh standard required to stop
and search people from reasonable and
articulable suspicion to probable cause
that's really all it does it does need
to do that in three separate paragraphs
but it's the same changes carried
through and again the intent is to align
that with a probable cause that is
required of every other law enforcement
agency I remember now fishion game Bill
there repres representative saor saor
sha thank you madam chair close enough
and representative Pap v m thank you for
taking my question sir um this only
applies to New Hampshire
uh does this only apply to New Hampshire
state fish and game officers it applies
to conservation officers yes they are
conservation officers so yeah it is
meant to apply to fish and game Law
Enforcement Officers
yes followup and that's state level law
enforcement yes they are a state agency
and uh you know they derive their
Authority from the state and again I'm
just trying to make sure that people
don't have to flip through a thick
lawbook to see what the rights are
yes y you good thank any anybody else
have any questions NOP seeing none thank
uh good afternoon um thank you for
having me here um my name is Kyle Baker
I am with the Wrath and Pignatelli firm
and I'm here on behalf of the New
Hampshire Wildlife Federation the
Hampshire Wildlife Federation is a
92-year-old nonpartisan nonprofit
organization that advocates for Hunting
Fishing and trapping as well as the
protection of and conservation of land
access in New Hampshire um we are
strongly opposed to this piece of
legislation um we have some um we are
the regulated community in this sense uh
we have a membership of over 55,000
Affiliated members 55 different fishing
game clubs the bear hunters the Trappers
Association um the bass fishermen um if
you can do it outside um they're
involved with our organization um unless
it has a motor that's a different
organization so um uh we are the regular
community in this um in this um sort of
matter and we see this as you know is
not a problem that we're facing um this
is the I think the 11th time a piece of
legislation in or around this particular
topic has come forward and we have
annual meetings and banquets and monthly
meetings um with all of our delegates
from all the various clubs around the
state and never once has anyone shown up
to one of our meetings saying they felt
that their rights were limited by a
conservation officers um the sportsmen
in New Hampshire are lucky to have a
very close relationship with our
conservation officers um they are
members of our communities members of
the the the sports and passions we
undertake um we also have concerns that
this would make New Hampshire a bit of
an island um when it comes to poaching
um this would be a different standard
for conservation officers in New
Hampshire than what our uh Partners on
both Vermont Maine and in Massachusetts
maintain um so we're worried that this
might make New Hampshire even bigger
magnet um for poaching activities um
throughout the state um again um this is
you know the expanded powers that
conservation officers have are held for
very limited circumstances um and I
think you know the colonel will get into
the specifics on where they can and
can't have extended circumstan uh search
Powers but again um just to be brief um
we don't see this as a problem that
needs to be fixed and we have concerns
about unintended consequences if
something were to move forward so happy
to answer any questions representative
brhs thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question could you give us uh
just
basically the the reasons why or why
it's so
important that the that the reasons that
you guys have the I guess the special
power that you
do uh sure so one example I've used is
um when it comes to shellfish right um
if if a conservation officer has a
reasonable articul suspicion that I'm
over the limit in the amount of
shellfish I've taken out of the Great
Bay or on the coast um if they're able
to stop and have that expanded search
Power um they may not have actively seen
me put you know X amount over the limit
into a cooler but if I've been there for
you know four or five hours and I'm
lugging a heavy cooler around they have
a reasonable articulable suspicion that
there's more than a you know a bushel or
half a bushel of oysters in my bucket so
um the ability for them to then stop me
question me check my fishing license and
inspect my catch um if I am over the
limit allows that conservation officer
the ability to return those oysters back
into the environment or another instance
may be um if I were to harvest a deer or
poach a deer um I can break down that
deer have it broken down in a relatively
short order and it can be frozen wrapped
and tucked away um relatively quickly um
and time is sort of of the essence in a
poaching case so having the ability of
an officer to see you know they might
see uh you know me they might see
antlers sticking out of the back of my
truck or something along those lines
that doesn't necess rise to the level of
probable cause but gives them that
reasonable and articulable suspicion
that they would have to prove in court
that they had that in order to make that
stop far to challenge their their
conviction so um time is sort of of the
essence uh when you're dealing with you
know live animals or harvested animals
so um that's why it's important to
us thank thank you I apologize I didn't
mean to say you as as and you were the
actual officer so thank
oh what additional Hoops would an
officer have to jump through to meet a
probable cause standard why don't we
wait for the officer to testify to that
okay perfect thank you see you no
further
wurn uh thank you for uh having me here
today so I could testify on this uh
against this bill um my name is Ward
burn I'm commercial lster fisherman out
of pors New Hampshire uh my vessel is a
fishing vessel sugar daddy and I'm here
to uh speak on the representation of the
New Hampshire your New Hampshire
commercial fisherman I I do have a
written statement and I'd like to share
a few other things did did you come two
years ago for this I sure did I I
thought I recognized you y change they
sure did uh this proposed change changes
under house bill HB 338 threatens to
devastate both the commercial and
recreational fishing industries by
undermining the ability of conservation
officers to effectively enforce
regulations fishing is a heavy heavily
regulated activity and inspections are
crucial in preventing Marine Resources
from f for future Generations limiting
officers to act upon probable cause
would waste valuable time allowing
violations to go unchecked in depleting
our ecosystem federal and state laws
currently work in harmony to ensure
sustainable resources and management but
this change would create damaging legal
conflicts fishermen who depend on these
resources to support our families
understand the value of inspections and
will willingly
submit to them to protect our
livelihoods without strong enforcement
illegal over ficient and violations
would jeopardize the biodiverse
and the long-term viability of our
fishing
economy time is money and waiting for
offices secure warrants would not only
hurt enforcement efforts but financially
hardwork and fishermen we cannot
afford to strip away the tools necessary
for sustainable fishery
management doing so risk destroy an
entire industry and our natural re
if I could add a few more things um New
Hampshire commercial
fishermen um work hand inand with the
New Hampshire fishing game conservation
officers we we have a tremendous
relationship it's been that way for
decades as long as I can
remember um I've never want I've been
boarded many times through the years
they basically drive up to our boats ask
us how we're doing and they as they they
ask they can uh do an inspection of our
catch and usually you know it's not like
they tie us up for a long time they they
go through a couple lobsters they check
some stuff out make sure we're whale
compliant make sure our trap has a tag
estate tags in it and they go along they
proper
venting and they go along their way and
that's pretty much it and all my time of
commercial fishing I've never once ever
felt like my constitutional rights were
in violation it's just not how it is
we work with them as much as they work
with us and this bill would
absolutely um put a strain on that for
one they would have to pull up to us and
this is my understanding how this bill
would actually work they would pull up
to say my
vessel um request permission to do an
inspection once that happens they have
to stop I have to stop
fishing and they have to type in a an
electronic email to a judge at the
courthouse and are my day is over and we
have to wait for the judge to issue the
warrant it is when we leave the dock
today dependent on the vessel in the
guwi hall every day we go to seea it's a
minimum of $600 worth of bait to a th000
depending on how much gear we're going
to all that would be very costly to
fishermen um I urge you to oppose this
bill it does nothing but hamper our New
Hampshire commercial fisherman and the
New Hampshire fishing game department
thank you thank you um you said that you
represent the the commercial fisherman
is that like a an organization of how
many how many members you have we we are
a uh New Hampshire commercial fisherman
is a 501c3 we are an organization in the
state um our we have
300 approximately 300 commercial fishing
licenses in the state now they're not
all active and I don't know the exact
number of of exact members but we we are
a strong
organization to that point you um you
generally don't necessarily always
testify in favor of the government and
in fact the federal government um
infringed on on your rights quite a bit
and I understand you guys spoke out
about it quite vociferously is that true
that's very true that was on a lsig
gauge increase and and as commercial a
fisherman we felt as though that our
data what what we see in the state and
federal data is not correct they're
seeing different things than we are and
um we came together and we stood up and
we actually uh we had a success we got
success from the from our governor thank
you Kelly aot she was big help to us and
um it was a it was a big deal to be able
to do that and um and this is the
commercial fishing industry is always
under the gun whether it's whales
whether it's windmills whether it's
gauge increases and now now this this is
my second time up there this week uh
testifying on trying to protect us as
fishermen and um well the point of my
question is you're uh you're no pushover
your group and if you didn't like this
bill you wouldn't be down here telling
us how great it was it absolutely so um
I appreciate it is there anything um any
other questions for the captain that's
title um my question has to do with your
statement about a warrant and it's it's
my observation that
that without a warrant is lined out and
I don't think a warrant is put back in
anywhere but it does raise it to the
highest degree of uh of evidence that
they have to prove so I'm not sure how
much of delay that would be to you now
um so we're going to have to probably
investigate that further to see
what that
is and do you agree with
that state that question again please
I'm a little
confused it doesn't appear that the a
warrant is required in the bill but
we'll discuss that it probably okay has
it been removed it's been deleted it
without a warrant is deleted and I don't
see anything here that says a warrant
and it was my understanding that it's
necessary to have a warrant to on our
boats if this is passed and I'm here to
speak against that that would be very
bad for the New Hampshire commercial
fisherman thank you very much the fact
that we we clear that up exective when
you the current state of the law is they
can board without a warrant scratching
that out means they would now need a
warrant to get it to go on their boats
and to apply for a warrant takes a long
time Argo he's here to tell us why
that's not a good
idea um and and and ultimately you know
the us fishermen are stewards of the sea
and we want to protect our resource and
and this
is it may not seem like it but it you
know working with wardens but it it
absolutely protects our resource it
keeps everyone and check they' be if
they're stuck with me all day they may
not be checking somebody else that's
that's not
compliant or saving somebody they saving
somebody
absolutely thank you uh see you no
further questions thank you for your
testing oh sorry Matt go ahead um um
would you believe that I do not believe
that the intent of this bill was to
require um you know the the author of
the bill that was not intending to
require warrant I believe that the
phrase without a warrant is scratched
out to further illustrate that the
authors of this bill do not want there
to be a warrant for for boarding I
believe that is the intent of the
bill would you believe
that I I don't I I would
we take a vote
yeah if if I may address yeah
um to require a warrant it needs to say
the word warrant by saying it basically
now says to Star and search and to
examine you have to have probable cause
it doesn't say you have to have a
warrant oh I see so I I don't think it
does require a warrant I think
representative Saban
theier is correct well to get a warrant
you you need probable cause so it it's
it's raising the the the standard to the
level of you might as well get a warrant
no
well here's the difference uh probable
cause is the standard to get a warrant
but do not have to get a warrant it it
it's a lot shorter true but the develop
probable cause based on a boat that you
can't yes it is a higher stand yeah it's
a higher standard okay I just wanted to
clarify the way it's written says is
that you do not need a warrant to stop
but you must have probable cause to stop
which is an increase in the the what how
the evidentiary rules are yeah so it
does not include a warrant I saw the
sponsor shaking his head back yeah for
the record mat is right yeah yeah but he
already rested his case once I many
times he needs to do so now now as a
fisherman I'm a little confused with
what's going on here oh yeah let me let
let me just break it down um they don't
need to Warrant If This Were have passed
they wouldn't have to have a warrant but
they would have to have probable cause
so that would just mean that their the
standard that they would need to look at
your catch would be higher than they
would previously um so right now they
need reasonable and articulable
suspicion which means I they could say
well um I saw this and this I thought
those were suspicious so I wanted to
look in the boat to probable cause means
it's um almost more likely than not that
you've committed a crime and I've
developed that information based on I
don't know what they're supposed to
develop that information based on
considering they're in the middle of the
ocean and but we'll we'll find out when
we hear from the colonel and I I would
uh encourage to keep the law the way it
is it works well for us it works well
for fishing game and I'll I'll leave it
at that thank you we appreciate you
coming down again thank you
thanks chief uh excuse me the um CH
Enders good afternoon my name is Steven
ERS I'm an assistant County attorney in
Marat County I also opposed the bill and
would asked to be found in expedient to
legislate um it sounds like a problem
that doesn't exist and I agreed that
striking the words without a warrant
creates ambiguity as to whether or not
you would need a warrant um if it if you
don't need a warrant I don't understand
what the difficulty with keeping the
language without a warrant would create
I think that would clear up that
ambiguity I think the fact that these
are referred to as conservation officers
is is telling in and of itself that
these are people who are trying to
conserve the resources of the State of
New Hampshire and there's a certain
balance between conser serving New
Hampshire's resources and sort of your
individual freedom to go about doing
whatever you want when it comes to
Hunting Fishing whatever and it seems to
me that Reasonable Suspicion would be
the proper standard and it sounds like
that is in fact a standard that's
working I would note that if this were
to pass to stop a person you would need
probable cause
whereas in sort of regular everyday law
enforcement law enforcement can stop a
person based on reason able suspicion so
this would create a scenario where for
example the gentleman who spoke before
me it would be easier to stop him
driving his car on the way to the dock
than it would be to stop his commercial
fishing boat which makes very little
sense to me I'm happy to answer
questions based on your experience
trying cases is it not your experience
that probable cause is often developed
based on conversations and
investigations that started with
Reasonable Suspicion absolutely um
Reasonable Suspicion is a lower standard
than probable cause and these standards
are sort of squishy to begin with when
it's not like a light bulb lights up
when you go from probable Reasonable
Suspicion to suddenly you now have
probable cause but I think generally
you'd find that probable cause is more
of an objective basis to believe that a
crime has been committed whereas
Reasonable Suspicion is a sort of
feeling based on reasonable articulable
facts that in fact there is a crime of
foot we're we're kind of focused on on
the ocean here but this also affects the
land so with regard to Hunters um in the
woods to require probable CA to stop a
hunter who's walking
um probable cause that they have
committed are about to commit a
crime can you think of any way that they
could possibly do that without first
engaging the
or just from seeing I mean even if they
were carrying a deer is that prob cause
that that they've poached it right no
absolutely not it would be very
difficult to to stop someone based on
probable cause which is I think why
generally law enforcements able to stop
a person based on Reasonable Suspicion
so you have that sort of Terry stop
based on Reasonable Suspicion which
allows you to detain a person and ask
them a moderate number of questions to
um you you know confirm or supel your
suspicions and that's Terry versus Ohio
not Terry chairman of the board here
just in case you're wondering um further
questions for the
Jordan I do have some testimony Sir with
good
afternoon jamond Roy and members of the
criminal justice I feel sorry for this
committee I come in here quite often and
watch your long days you have some of
the longest days of all the people in
the house so thank you for your service
very much we have been here uh I think
11 or 12 times on this um it is very
confusing for folks that don't
understand it I we spend uh first of all
let me start by saying my name um um I
am here in opposition to House Bill 338
after uh having a vote from my entire
Fishing Game Commission my name is Kevin
Jordan I'm the current chief of law
enforcement New Hampshire fishing game
I've served in the Colonel's position
for the past decade now and I am
entering my 34th year serving in law
enforcement so I've had a little bit of
experience in stopping and
searching
um and so I'll start by saying this
before you make a decision regarding
this it needs to be I think a clear
understanding and I really appreciate
the County Attorney coming in because I
he hit on some very important points
there's a big difference between
articulable suspicion and probable cars
uh probable car in on New Hampshire and
I'll compare it to New Hampshire
roadways because I think that's what
people are most familiar with and try to
bring you back to how we stop people so
if you were stopped on your on your in
your car on the roadway that stop was
based primarily mostly on articulable
suspicion it's virtually impossible if
you want to end motor vehicle stops
create this law for the police
departments and motor vehicle stops will
come to a screeching halt because you
just can't develop probable cause
watching a car go down the road it's
just not enough so you stop the car and
then you get to the driver and you check
the license which is a search by the way
the minute you ask for that driver's
license by our court findings that's a
search uh and then you would work to
develop probable cause if in fact there
is there is a crime a foot prob cause is
a standard that is 51% or higher likely
that a reasonable and prudent person
would uh be of the opinion that a crime
has been committed or about to be
committed or that evidence of a crime
exist and exactly where that evidence is
located that's a lot that's a pretty
high standard and our attorney general's
office as well as our courts without
many exceptions have said to us in law
enforcement when you have probable
caruse you will apply for a search
warrant and they only give us a very few
number of exceptions of when you don't
have to do that and they're all
involving Exogen circumstances things
like chasing a a felon who has just shot
at someone and has run into a building
they will allow you to go in there and
search for them um the the car being a
mobile unit and that's gone both ways
but a lot of times that's decided that
it's exigent but but other and domestic
and some levels of domestic violence but
other than that you are required by New
Hampshire law 595 to get a warrant and
this law even though I think the
representative really tried to um
to write this so that we wouldn't have
to get a search warrant I I would never
bring a case into a courtroom with
probable cause and no search warrant and
no excy because I would get it bounced
out I can tell you I've had them bounced
out over the years so those two things
go together and the second part of this
bill starting on line um
is is most concerning when it comes to
the commercial fishing industry starting
on line 13 under marine species search
and seizures under RSA 21175 to board
any boat which is on a public water
Waters under the jurisdiction of the
state if the conservation officer has
probable cars that essentially means we
wouldn't be stopping boats I can't go on
a boat I'm not going to be able to
develop probable caruse on a boat with a
pair of binoculars at 50 yards I can't
measure lobsters using a gug age unless
I board the boat and physically take the
Lobster in hand to measure it I can't
tell if it's a female egg bearing
Lobster which is so crucial to the state
and to the fisherman law demands that we
release it immediately we can't even
hold it for court I have to take a
picture of it and release it back into
the waters that's how critical it is to
our habitats I can't do that from a
distance with a pair of binoculars so we
would not be able to stop boats in state
waters however 3 miles out federal law
would allow me to do all of those things
so the Federal law this would conflict
with federal law they allow us to do it
because the federal authorities so the
government has and many other most other
states have have long debated this and
decided that these resources are
important they're critical to the to the
survivability of the resource that we
allow that on a limited basis I'm going
to tell you something I run a tight
I love my people I'm very proud of
every single one of men and women that
we have now but I run a tight ship and I
in America and I don't want to be
searched uh illegally any more than any
of you do and we have very carefully
instruct our officers on how to do that
and I really like hearing from people
like Ward who tolerates this regularly
and he's one of thousands of people that
we board boats and that we encounter in
the woods and I really like the fact
when he says that this is brief the the
officers are polite they they do what
they're supposed to do to check for
these compliance and they let these
folks go along their merry way because I
can assure you if a warrant is required
for us the other thing that's unique for
us again Troopers and and when I was a
patrolman on the highway I was on a I
was on a roadway I was close to town or
close to my PD those days are long gone
we're in the woods I'm in the woods five
miles back sometimes or further on these
remote ponds I'm not sure how I would
check a fisherman on a remote Pond that
we air stock because I can't get a truck
in there if I get to the point where I
got to get probable cars and I got to go
go get a warrant he's going to go for a
hike with me for the day until we get a
warrant is it or more likely my officers
are just going to ignore it they're not
going to do it and and they're going to
ride around and drink coffee which is a
shame and so our resources will be raped
and it will not take long to do that uh
on opening day any opening day of
fishing you find 50 to 100 fishermen on
a on a stock trout pond and I've got one
officer trying to watch those folks he
can't possibly see them all and he's got
to see him catch an over limit to
develop probable cause and then go get
his warrant hopefully we'll have cell
phone coverage or we'll have Wi-Fi or
Internet coverage which again is spotty
at best uh throughout our
state
um this law has been on the books this
is very important I think this law has
been on the books since 1930 so we have
had 90 years of judicial review 90 years
ladies and gentlemen of defense
attorneys and prosecutors and judges who
have heard this law or heard this start
of an investigation based on theth ities
provided in this law I am very confident
when I say to you that if any of this
violated anyone's rights we would have
heard about it some time ago and it
would have changed it has been appealed
interestingly three times to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court first case was
State V Kimble and it involved a bob
house with one of my officers going into
a bob house based on articulable
suspicion that case was upheld by our
Supreme Court as being constitutional
the their ability they looked
specifically at this particular statute
20626 the next case was State V
bman I find it interesting that Justice
Lynn affirmed this decision he was on he
was in the Supreme Court and he held
that this law was constitutional in that
particular case I think that's important
um that and we prevailed in that case
that was where an officer uh entered a
piece of property uh and the defendant
claimed he had no right to be there and
and so 20626 was reviewed and affirmed
as being constitutional the third case
was in 19 1973 it involved a lobster
fisherman a gentleman by the name of
Marone no relation I don't believe to
the current Marone family down there and
again that involved uh boarding a boat
checking for lobster catches um all of
those objections were raised um uh about
us being able to board a boat and the
Supreme Court again upheld that this law
was constitutional that it is necessary
to ensure the rights of all citizens to
enjoy these resources and that these
stops are brief uh these people are
engag enging in activities uh uh based
on uh choice not privilege not rights uh
and so if they feel it is a violation of
their constitutional rights you can
simply not participate in it um I don't
know how I would enforce you folks Chang
the law for us a number of years ago
involving lead tackle to protect our
environment you can't fish using lead I
wouldn't be able to check for that we
have to physically look at the tackle to
see that I wouldn't be able to check for
steel shot and a shotgun we we determine
that shooting lead on the water fou over
our waterways poisons our Waters and our
loons um the only way I can tell if
someone shooting a lead shot going off
in a shotgun sounds identical to a steel
shot the only way I can tell the
difference between lead and steel is to
check it with a magnet so the officers
go out on during duck season and check
rounds with magnets we wouldn't be able
to do that if we needed probable cause
none of these things would occur another
very important piece is we receive I
averaged it out for about 3 years we
receive almost a half a million dollars
from National marine fisheries uh no
um There You Go sir yes sir think I
should have signed you up for a witness
you've done a great job today um
National Marine
atmospheric um Administration provides
almost a half a million dollars to New
Hampshire fishing game and so that is
used for my officers on the coastline
and and they get that Grant because they
are down there checking Federal
compliance I for right whales for
lobster traps as Mr bird very accurately
described um if we were not able to do
that if we were restricted from doing
that which this law would now prevent us
from doing unless we had probable cars
we would lose that funding we'd lose
that half million dollar funding that
saves the state a lot of money I buy
equipment with it down there uh we use
it for boats and it pays the officer
salaries working on the coast so that
would now fall to the state cence um I
can go into I have those court cases if
anyone is ever interested in seeing the
quotes from them but the quotes are very
similar to what I've said the reasoning
for um not ruling this as
unconstitutional and the final thing or
one of the thing I want to leave you
with is the uh State of California is
arguably and I don't I hope I don't
offend anyone but arguably it is
probably the most liberal state in the
country the state of California heard
this case involving a commercial
fisherman based on an officer in Wild
the wildlife enforcement out there that
stopped a commercial fisherman searched
or actually checked checked his catch
much like we do on a daily basis found
short lobsters convicted him of it and
it went all the way to the the
California Supreme Court and they in
fact held that this law was not
unconstitutional that it was important
for fishermen and they gave very similar
reasons to our own State uh cases so uh
and I would ask you to to before you
vote on this I would ask you to think
about the last time that you heard a New
Hampshire conservation officer being on
the front page of any newspaper or any
news article violating anyone's rights I
will challenge you that that has never
occurred it certainly hasn't in my three
decade of service we have an exculpatory
list evidence list that I know you're
familiar with where officers are listed
when they violate the law they violate
the rights of citizens again I've never
known of a New Hampshire Conservation
office ever being on it um I I think
they're doing this right I think they're
fair I think they're professional I'm
very proud of them and I would ask you
not to strip them of their powers which
is exactly ly what this bill would do
but to let us do our job the way been
we've been doing it and uh and I thank
you for your patience and support that
I've always seen in this
committee thank you Colonel um couple a
couple questions um we talk about
fishermen we talk about hunters but what
about just a regular Joe who's out there
on his boat um who seems could
potentially get caught up in this yes so
if I'm out there just for the day on my
on my boat and we're just out
sightseeing um I don't particularly care
about how long you take to search a
lobster boat or anything like that I
just want to enjoy the weather and sure
so I don't necessarily want to consent
to just being boarded for no particular
reason absolutely how do you handle that
case so and I should have explained that
so give you some examples of how we how
we function so when I go out on a
freshwater lake and it's fishing season
and i' I've got binoculars I'm watching
people with binoculars before I approach
them because I want to make sure that we
are looking for fishermen and I see that
boat and I see a family on it which is
quite common and so the first thing you
look for is do they have fishing gear on
board are they fishing yeah if you don't
see fishing gear then the next thing I
look for is I might check I might check
to see if the boats registered Marine
Patrol normally does that but if I'm out
there and I'm looking for that I'll look
for that I may look to see if we have
children on board and if in fact those
children have life preservers other than
that I'm going to wave and wish you a
great day because I don't have that
articulable suspicion and that's what I
teach these guys another example is
you you are watching Fisherman along a
along a brook fishing fisherman is there
you didn't you didn't see him catching
fish but he is now leaving by the time
you got down to him he is headed your
way and he's got his fishing equipment
in his hand and he has a backpack on and
so you approach him things you you look
you know he's fished I feel very
comfortable asking him for his license
my next conversation with him would be
did you have any luck today you catch
any fish and well yes I did I caught two
brook trout can you mind if I take a
look at those brook trout and they'll
present those 99% of the time if he says
no I didn't catch any fish and he acts
suspicious he acts nervous or he you
know I have some sort of idea that maybe
something is a miss here I might engage
him in further conversation I might look
at the backpack do I see water on it do
I see it wet um I'm not allowed by this
law to go tear off his backpack and
unzip it and go through all the
compartments I mean I can do that you're
not going to be able to use any of that
in a in a courtroom
um that doesn't give us you can't go
into the guy's front pockets when you're
looking for a deer right um and people
have accused us you know you guys use
your powers to circumvent that no you
you've got to be able to articulate that
you saw uh Blood on the trunk of a
vehicle so you opened the trunk or you
asked the individual to open the trunk
or I saw I saw moisture in the backpack
so I had a I had an idea there were fish
in there but that boater or someone's
you know we drive in boat launches all
the time and and somebody guy standing
there with his date and he there's no
fishing gear I have a friendly
conversation with them and I get out of
their hair I I have no right to ask them
anything so you have to have because you
have to articulate that you know in a
courtroom you know that Jim androy that
you have to be able to explain in a
courtroom and in a report what started
this conversation and it better be solid
because they'll they'll kick it um you
know today's courts I think are more in
tune to this than ever uh is my opinion
and we have uh great I don't know if you
were a defense attorney but I've
listened to you and I have a feeling
that you are we have great defense
attorneys and and if there's a hole if
there well if there's a hole you're
going to have they're going to go into
that hole and you're going to have to
explain that so yes we ignore that you
ignore that and and if if by accident
you encounter that and you don't see
fishing gear you apologize and send them
on their way on the contrary if you're
talking to them and they act suspicious
that you may develop based on they could
have smuggled they could be full of
fenel in in the whole at a boat yeah um
and we don't we don't the other thing we
don't do that we've been accused of
doing is is many times people have said
that other agents we have good
relationships with other agencies and
they take they use us for these search
BS I absolutely prohibit that if this if
it hasn't got something to do with
fishing game don't call me out to 93 to
search a trunk because you think I have
the authority and you don't that again
this is America I'm not going to to
we're not going to tolerate that and and
again you're not going to win that
you're not going to win Court already
ruled on those a lot of things that we
are required to do by you by in statutes
that you have created there's a lot of
commercial Fisheries laws that we have
to do uh by holding things in our hand
and and those are searches folks the
minute you do that and to base it all on
probable cause we can do that but you're
going to limit if not eliminate the
opportunity to check these things and it
won't take long for things to go right
or and Ward explained it pretty well if
you do develop that problem CA now I'm
going to tie a fisherman up for the day
while I go get a warrant which is
crazy if just for the so everyone
understands the committee and who may be
listening what is the standard to make
an
arrest to make an arrest you must have
probable costs so the the this bill
would require you to meet the standard
you would have to meet to make an arrest
before you even found the evidence
before you could even check before you
before you could even check evidence it
it it twist it around you're exactly
right okay yeah any further
questions oh that I'm now I'm
nervous see you no further questions
thank you thank very much anyone else
anyone else wishing to testify in this
bill who has not done so seeing none I
here by close the public
left
e
now here I open the public hearing to
whatever the spill is um
343 343 and invite the prime sponsor to
introduce her Bill thank you Mr chair
and honorable members of the committee
for the record my name is alisandra
Murray I represent Manchester Ward 9
Hillsboro District 20 um and I am
reintroducing a bill that we passed um
out of this committee 19 to1 last year
it simply codifies into our existing
statute um specific data that we would
like to see reported from the northern
border iance um I pulled up the most
recent report they did for comparison um
I might potentially bring forward an
amendment before we exec on this just to
align it a little bit better with what
they're currently um already
reporting but the piece I kind of want
to hone in on here is um collecting the
data and Reporting the data on where
these individuals that are being
detained reside if you look at the
activity that's been reported in the
past quarter from the northern border
Alliance they had over 1700 contacts
with individuals 668 motor vehicle stops
608 warnings 68 citations 25 criminal
investigations 21 arrests and out of all
that only four of them were individuals
that were um detained for crossing the
border illegally so so for
me I would be interested in figuring out
who the rest of these people are are
they just individuals who live in that
area and if so um I mean I think we can
use the data to make better
determinations and how we're allocating
this funding to this program again
especially going into such a tight
budget year and in a different um
scenario we are now on the national
level that I personally think maybe the
data will help us um you know better
allocate um the funding and ensure that
um we're not just duplicating Federal
efforts essentially especially since the
data seems to indicate um that the work
they're doing is largely not what we
intended them to do simply
circumstantially but that's about it
thank you
questions representa
Muse thanks for taking my question my
understanding is that some of this data
is already being collected it's just not
being reported is that correct yes yes
so we would essentially be asking for um
when they have these citation forms or
you know the reports that they're
filling out when they have these stops
just to provide the information that
they're already collecting on those
reports thank
you you you said originally in your
testimony that um out of can you repeat
again the numbers of how many out of so
many were just that part if you don't
mind yeah um so for ohrv and pedestrian
contacts it's 1722
yeah motor vehicle stops 668 yeah
warnings
608 citations and summons issued is 68
25 criminal investigations 21 arrests
and out of all of that only four were
individuals who were cited for illegally
crossing the border cited or detained or
I mean four were assist to border patrol
yeah so we don't know really what that
was
mhm are you aware that during the
previous administration they were not
allowed to detain people they were just
given a summons and
released I wasn't but I do know that the
program originally came from concerns
like with how the federal Administration
previously was handling um the northern
border um concerns around the northern
border but I also think that those
concerns are not um as valid considering
the new Administration no I'm curious I
want to know if we can get more detailed
information then just that doesn't tell
me much no it literally just says yeah
for assists to border patrol um and then
they do have information here on what
the other arrests were for but it
doesn't say anything about who those
people were that were arrested so you
know there's one that's like aggravated
driving while intoxicated one that's
suspended on registration one that's on
a warrant for theft you know these are
things that you know people should be
getting arrested for but probably by
local law enforcement not specially
deputized law enforcement agents that
are supposed to be patr border I believe
the vast majority are state troopers and
so they are they don't need to be
deputized yeah but they are acting as a
force multiplier up in these areas where
there's very sparse law enforcement just
because of it's so um it's so remote so
I know that that's there's there they're
trying to get dual use out of it but I
would like more information um further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you anyone else is there anyone else to
so seeing none I he by Clos the public
wait
e
I'm opening executive session on House
Bill 468 relative to
drones um and I'm going recognize myself
to offer an amendment that I can't seem
to put my hands on yeah uh the motion is
ought to
pass with the following Amendment where
is
it yeah could you give me another copy
and seconded by representative Harry
gath thank you I got it I'll keep that
one that's
s um I'll speak to my motion uh this
bill was heard by the committee last
week we we um for those who don't
remember why this was brought the um
there's serious safety
concerns by our state police with regard
to how drones are being operating who's
operating them um there's been an
amendment to add um a couple things one
an exemption for our press cor so that
they are still allowed to do their work
and another was added with regard to um
fire interfering with firefighting
equipment
because we saw what just happened in
California with a drone flying into I
believe some type of firefighting
aircraft um other than that it's as it
was I think this is a very important
bill right now given the security
situations that have been articulated To
Us by our department of safety so that
is the reason I'm asking you to pass
this bill uh would you like to speak to
your second representative gaat
right thank you anyone wish to discuss
this
bill seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the role the motion on the floor is
ought to pass with this amend actually
this adopting this amendment and the
amendment number is
Hotel Vice chair roads yes
representative lels yes representative
devoid yes representative pette yes
representative subor D Schwaner yes
representative harri
gther representative Muse yes
representative Newman yes representative
Murphy yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Shear yes and chairman Roy chotes yes
130 13 z um that's unanimous
correct i' now recogniz myself to make a
motion of ought to pass with
Amendment second Thank You seconded by
representative rhods um I don't ises any
wish any further discussion I think we
covered it see none asked the clerk to
call the role the motion is out to pass
with Amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative LEL yes representative
pette or sorry devoid yes representative
pette yes representative Sabor D
Schwaner yes representative Harry gther
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative new yes
representative shear yes chairman Roy
chair votes yes 130 any objection to
consent seeing none going consent it's
passed unanimously um and does this have
note is it me or does every bill this
year have a fiscal note miraculously for
some reason um I we'll see what is it
indeterminant yeah it seems like they
put notes on everything and said
indeterminate this year want us to hold
it for the budget but that what that's
doing is it's it's jaming fiscal all
right um well I'm going to try and put
it on consent and try and figure out why
our bills are all being done this way um
with that I close the executive session
I open the executive session on House
Bill
196 oh whoops and I move ought to pass
with Amendment an amendment number I
offer is
seconded by representative um Sher um uh
speak to the amendment when the bill was
heard um was brought to us by um
representative wheeler again this year
um there were some concerns that one it
was going to put an enormous workload on
the court system and thereby creating a
lot of expense as well um and the
second concern
I think that was the biggest one that
was changed in this is really that um it
but let me just speak to it briefly
there's a little bit to like and a
little bit to hate for everybody in this
bill um which is probably makes it a
good piece of legislation it it lets us
forgive mistakes made and useful and
Discretions but it it doesn't go overly
broad so it has to be a misdemeanor or a
violation level offense it has to be a
standalone offense so there's no
piggybacking on you know getting your
your pot conviction reversed that was
part of a an armed robbery it had to be
for the PO conviction um getting these
things you may think well why why is it
important to get rid of this is there's
a lot of things you can't join the
military as was raised um by one of our
members and I didn't even think of this
with this conviction on your record you
can't join the military so if you if
this happened to you when you were 17
and dumb or 18 you're you're done you
can't ever join the military um Firearms
can't own firearms you have drug
convictions um you can't ever get a
security clearance so let's say all
right I'm not going to go in military
but I do want to work for the FBI no you
can't so there's a lot as a society back
during the Great War on Drugs we put a
lot of emphasis on penalizing this but
it's penalizing people for the rest of
their lives when it not need not do so
so I think that um it's time we practice
what we preach and we exercise a little
forgiveness um and and I understand
there are still some concerns about
people who have made pled down and took
the simple misdemeanor and it could have
been a felony um you know and and those
are valid concerns but we I don't feel
like we should retain this this um damic
sword hanging over everybody for the
rest of their lives because of the few
that took a plea deal um and with that
uh would you like to speak to your
second representative share uh very
least one I like your use of the word
uh um second uh it also uh uh a
marijuana conviction can affect uh your
accessibility of subsidized
housing and potentially your family's
accessibility to uh subsidize housing um
so another
reason it seems like the the reasons to
do this keep adding the more you discuss
it um open for discussion anybody else
would like to add their their thoughts
on
this okay um with that I would ask the
clerk to call the role this is on the
amendment uh adopting amendment number
0192 Hotel Vice chair roads yes
representative Lal yes representative
devoid yes representative pette yes
representative saor deer yes
representative Harriet gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy your VES yes 13 zero 130 it is
adopted uh motion now I would now
recognize myself for a motion to pass
with
Amendment who wants it who okay uh
representative gather seconded um I
believe we've discussed all the reasons
unless someone thought of some more in
the last two seconds why we should pass
this um seeing none I ask cler to call
the
role Vice chair roads yes representative
LEL yes representative devoid yes
representative pette yes representative
saor desier yes representative Harriet G
yes representative Muse yes
representative Newman yes representative
Murphy yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Shear yes chairman Roy chair vots 130
130 the motion passes um any objection
to consent seeing none it will try to go
on consent um and with that I close the
executive session it's my understanding
that representative wheeler will be
supplying Pizza in the Next
[Laughter]
problem yeah no